Okay.
Podcast is brought to you
by the flashlight. If you're
going to Joe rogan.net,
click on the link for the fleshlight
and entering the code named Rogan.
You will get 15% off a $1 one sex
toy from this wonky ass set up.
I can never get these fucking cameras
to stay straight. There you go.
Fill a
flashlight.
Commercial done. That's it. No,
I'll give you a little more.
It's a fucking great product to an
embarrassing product, but it's excellent.
It's very effective for what it does.
Oh these things are going to
be on a space station soon.
I've got $100 they should
be on the space station.
Why should they make those people just
stay up in space and not be able to fuck
a little, not to mention like
jerking off in space. Yeah.
I feel like strictly prohibited
from having sex up there.
Well yeah cause you're going to have
your come floating through the space
station. This is why the flashlight's
great out there cause it catches your jet.
That's right. Perfect for the space
station. It's American, it's NASA,
it's fucking NASA.
NASA type technology and it's the best
feeling false. With Johnny, you can get,
well I shouldn't even say false
artificial or would you say false?
Why wouldn't I?
Because it makes me feel bad.
I'm judging the fishes
better. Some false. It's,
it's a rule of fake one. It's definitely
feels like you're fucking her pussy.
A really good one too.
And a dead one.
Especially if you go out of your
way when you could make it warm.
I don't do that.
Anytime I'm about a flashlight.
It's I'm way past eating out for thing.
How often do you prepare and
actually like lay out some water.
He a bath with the flashlight and the
Bab so it soaks in the warm water and
you'd have to figure out what's, what's
realistic. It's 100 degrees realistic.
Are you fucking a girl with a fever?
A marathon runner? A girl.
Mid Marathon. But I did.
I did it once. I did try to heat
up a flashlight. I was like,
I'm gonna fucking,
I put it under the sink and turn it up,
turn the water on hot and just let the
hot water. It's the same thing. We like,
fuck this,
I'm fucking this thing.
You have to poach it slightly.
We'll temperature.
What if you had like a,
like a crazy fetish for banging a
chip that's dying of fever and shit.
The one last thing,
she wants you to fucker malaria.
It's just so hot and sweaty and she just
shaking and last last gasps of air and
her favorite thing is fucking so
she was like, just fuck me. Yeah.
You would fly to villages in Africa that
were like afflicted with malaria and
you would go there and pay the
villagers money to let them fuck.
You know, it's fucked up. As
fucked up as that. Dawn is.
Someone out there has it
legitimately, you know, there's,
there's 7 billion of us now. How
many people on it? I don't know.
I lost count.
We also brought to you by [inaudible]
Dot com o n n I t, makers of Alpha brain.
I take my Alpha brain before the show.
Let's see if I fall apart.
I take it before anything important.
What is it? It's a, it's a neutral beck.
I take it every day essentially,
but I make sure I take it,
but like before I beat to the UFC,
I take three or four of them before I do
comedy and take three or four of them.
Usually I only take like two in a day,
maybe four.
But what it is is a nootropics are, and
by the way, this is just me. I mean it's,
it's not dangerous yet.
None of these levels of dangerous,
but you might not like it.
You might think it makes you too jittery.
I've had like I've taken three
before in a row and I'm like, man,
this makes me feel like a little edgy.
Almost like I'm caffeine down a little
bit, but usually two, two is good.
Two is good for stand up,
two's good for anything.
Anything intense is going to take
more than four or five hours,
usually take three. Nowadays they
also seem to combat hangovers.
It's great for jet lag too.
We'll do whatever the fuck's going on
in your brain when it's not working that
well. Obviously there's a lack of
something. What is that? I Dunno,
but these,
these nutrients,
supposedly the science behind it is that
it helps your body produce human neuro
transmitters in May. It helps
you produce all the, you know,
all the shit that makes your brain fire.
Yeah. It's, what's that stuff called?
It's called [inaudible]
doesn't it have, what's the shit you
take after you take ecstasy the next day?
Oh yeah, I be five HTP
is a nootropic. Yeah,
that's the thing we have called new mood.
Five HTP m also El Tryptofan because
ultra defend converts to five HTP and the
body and that enhances your body's
ability to produce serotonin. Yeah.
There's ways you can manipulate the levels
of nutrients in your body and it has
an effect,
a real effect on the way your brain works.
But don't just listen to me please Google
nootropics and there's a lot of other
companies out there that
have real good products.
I mentioned Bill Graham
analyses and neuro one.
I liked that one a lot and it's got like
a little caffeine in it. Um, if she,
at least mine. Really? Yeah.
What's it called? Pain at brain.
The them, the guy jerks off logo and
sharks. These responsibilities makes
it so that you can easily share gear
with spot without feeling guilty.
Like before I would play world for like
four hours straight and I feel terrible.
Now I'm Beta brain.
I can play world of Warcraft for
two days straight shit myself.
Shred them guilt. It's great stuff guys.
You compartmentalize essentially. Yeah,
you can't, you just don't feel
the guilt. You just let it go.
The guilt just gets blocked.
It's gone wrong. Naps.
You could jerk off five times a day
without feeling like a loser on Beta.
Brain waves break, check it out. We'll
be, we'll be looking into that as well.
If you're interested in alphabet,
Joe rugged.net, click on the link,
enter in the code name Rogan and you will
get 10% off any and all orders. We're,
we're absolutely not trying to rip anybody
off with any of this stuff and that's
the reason why we have a 100% money
back guarantee on the first order of 30
pills. When you buy it, if you ride it,
you don't even have to send it back.
Just so this stuff sucks.
Give me my money back.
We are now trying to rip anybody off.
This is all stuff I would be taken whether
or not I had any financial stake in
the company.
Uh, with Beta brain, I have frank,
no financial stake in the company and
with the first 50 pills you order,
you get a lavender scented face mask.
It should be with Beta brain
for the first, you know,
first three years of the company.
All of the money goes to
all of your ex's anyway.
Yeah, that's right.
Yeah. It's flowers. Yeah.
Could you imagine if that was
the way the world works? If you,
you entered into contracts and
you know, as you, as you left,
like you would have to agree to be with
this woman or pay for this one for 10
years and then don't have sex with you.
What if is what's just with friendship?
What if you had to get married to your
friend and being friends with people you
have to like sign a contract with like
we're going to be friends forever.
Yeah. And you can't just miss miss
him on a weekend once or twice.
You gotta do what I'm constantly,
no,
and if you fucking break that contract
that you got to keep your friend like 10%
of your anchor.
I bet people have done,
I mean isn't that what gay marriage as
essentially it's just friends or fuck
each other cause they're dudes.
I think that's what marriage is,
right? Yeah. Fuck each other.
That's why having a girlfriend is, it's
a friend that you fuck, right girl.
I took our old friend,
that's how they call it.
It's just a friend that you like to put
your Dick inside of what it is. Yeah,
absolutely. So now that act of doing that
at the moment you put your cock inside,
somebody changes the game. Yeah. Oh
yeah.
Anyway, enough about Alpha
brain talk. That commercial,
it's essentially over right now. Well,
there's new mood, shroom tech, sport,
True Tech,
Moon and Alpha brain and all the
different things that we saw it on it.
O N N I t.com coming up,
we got kettlebells and a bunch
of other cool nutritional things.
You know, Beta brain also has a mood
enhancing drug. It's called blue mode.
It makes it so that you can like
really listen to Elliot Smith. Love it.
I wonder if the,
if the,
if someone could sell pills that made
you depressed and he would buy him,
he would buy them.
I mean,
look at what it's cigarettes
once or something that
makes you feel like shit and
smelled terrible. And yet there
though, like it's super popular.
Kills people and it's super popular.
If you had depression pills and
you just had them out there, yeah,
it would be like a news story.
News at five is this new
pill crossing the line.
It's marketed as depression.
And then you go there and there's a chick
with white makeup on a black lipstick
and she goes, life fucking sucks.
It's always fucking sucked. Okay.
And when I take these pills, I see Audi
and that's what I want. If you are, I get,
fuck. Yeah. Yeah.
What is wrong with the children of today
is this depression drug crossing the
line.
Happiness is annoying when
you're around happy people,
they're fucking irritating. If you're
happier fucking piece of shit. Yeah.
What are you,
what's there to be happy about?
You're going to fucking die in a few
years. Russian wars raging everywhere.
You really going to walk around with
a smile on your face and this economy.
Well no,
it's really good to do.
Depression was your girl cause when
you get through it and it wears off,
it's like he gets a really
appreciate how good.
How could you have it right when
you're getting along great. Yeah,
because when you take depression,
it's really like going through like
one of those life changing experiences.
I'm mood African drugs that make you
like almost die and then we have a
combination of those crazy
drugs that they give,
like the jungle drugs
where you almost die.
It's not quite a psychedelic experience.
It's almost like a near death
experience. Like, literally,
literally am most kill you ready?
Cool.
And you're supposed to like learn
something about yourself through,
through this intense
and horrible poisoning.
I think they're called ordeal
poisons. That's the actual
technical term. And they,
um, they, they operate very similar to
psychedelics in the way that they humbly,
you mean, cause it really brings
you to the brink of death and your,
your emotions are just
blaring your fuse are blaring,
your, you know, insecurities.
And when, you know,
I think you're forced to examine your
life in a very deep and realistic way in
any real, true near tragic
situation. Right? Oh yeah.
So I think you take these ordeal poisons
and you just go through the ordeal of
almost fucking dying and you learned a
little bit about yourself, but God dammit,
that's the hard way to do it.
That is the hard way to do it.
But for a lot of people,
that's the only way to do it.
Yeah.
Yeah. They don't have enough love
in a psychedelic free environment.
I can't get it to them. So they don't
have the means to get it to them.
Yeah. I mean sometimes even, I mean,
people will take psychedelics
and still be douche bags.
Totally. That guy we were talking
about before a show. Yeah.
It was a lot of them out there,
but they're like,
it's almost like by taking it and allows
you to be a Twat because you've had the
experience and you're allowed to
like stick it in someone else's face.
It hasn't had the experience of their,
their children or their a moron.
Like that's, that's, that's crazy.
What are, you know, you're not,
you're not better for having an
experience. You're just more experienced.
You know, what, what's better is
your overall impact on human beings.
And if Justin,
your accumulated some extra information
so you feel it's okay to be conti,
well that's not better at all.
You just moved your energy into a
different direction. You're not,
you're not better. Right.
You're still being a Twat.
Well, you're still differentiating.
Yeah. That's it. That's the, the,
um,
and the Bhagavad of I get,
it sort of talks about like signs of
people who've gained real realization.
And one of the signs is that they don't
differentiate between any anything.
It's all, they see it as all an
expansion of the same original force.
They don't see it anymore.
It's like this person's rich,
this is person or this person's good, this
person's bad. It's all just different,
uh,
sides and angles and this super structure,
there's a existed
forever. That's so hard
to do, to think that way.
It's so hard to separate yourself from,
you know,
from you and your needs and your,
your ideas are you what you want and
what you want to accomplish or what or
whatever.
Yeah.
Whenever you associate with you and
the idea that you're a part of a whole,
well, you could end up actually
imagine it really being in that state.
The only time I've ever truly
been in that state was, uh,
when I had taken a huge dose of
Lsd and was out in the desert.
And I remember just having that fading
away merging thing where you no longer
anything. You're just, you're, you're
everything. You just merge into it all.
And I don't know how you would
really function in that state.
I don't really know what you would
be like in the world if he, if,
if you've got didn't, if that lasted
longer than the amount of time, you know,
an acid trip is or a few hours.
But they do say that through
meditation and through, um,
strict yoga disciplines,
you can hit that place permanently,
you know,
and somehow that that place
is Nirvana or paradise.
It's a beautiful way to be all the
time. But I don't know. I haven't,
you know,
I've only heard stories about people like
that descriptions and people like, uh,
he was a corpse that the universe spoke
through as one great description of wow.
You know, or the, the, the
ego of the person was dead.
They're just gone.
But that would probably boring as fuck
to hang out with cus the problem. Right.
You know,
part of what's cool about being a human
being is being around people that have
some flavor.
Yeah. Hell yeah. And you, you know,
you see some of these people and they
do seem to have flavor. So, you know, I,
I don't know the problem with talking
about the holy men of the world,
the great holy man, if the world is
that I've never met one. It's like
I've met some want to be gurus,
quite a few want to be gurus
and some of them, you know,
they shock me with they're humorless.
You know what though dude, I did do a
video chat with Ron Bass. You still,
there was a man, that guy was
fucking awesome and it lit up.
My whole apartment was just you and
him. Yeah, it was, no, it was me,
him and Natasha. Wow. Yeah.
How did you arrange this?
Well,
on its website you can still do it.
It's this thing called heart to hearts
where you can like know you can talk to
him on Sunday. Wow. And you
just go to the website and up.
I couldn't believe it either.
I thought it was,
there was no way it was going to work
or I thought they were going to like try
to get asked for money from
me or something like, but
I sign up for it Sunday,
my phone rang. Hello
Duncan. It's Ron doss.
Holy Shit.
Yeah. And then suddenly I'm like
on this video screen with Ron Doss,
and he was glowing. He was like,
he's an old dude now that he's,
it was like exactly the same energy that
my friends, eight year old kids have.
It was just this radiant,
childlike, authentic energy.
It wasn't phony. It wasn't bullshit. Wow.
We talked for a little while. He told me,
um,
this chant that he's been doing lately
over and over again where he says,
I am loving awareness. I am loving
awareness. I am loving awareness.
It's a chance to just sort of, I don't
know, shift your vibe. And then that was,
it said goodbye. And that was it.
They didn't ask for any money.
They didn't want anything. It
was just a wow, you know? Yeah.
I was just like service.
That's okay.
That's fascinating. That's
fascinating. Yeah. It's like,
look at him and you know, people who, uh,
are insane psychedelic enthusiasts.
You know,
you look at someone like him and you go,
there's a guy he made it through. Yes.
You made it through. I
really grabbed it. Yeah.
He really grabbed a hold of the whole
thing and it made him something different
and made him what he is at the,
at the heart of the trip.
That's right now. Well, he,
because what happened is he went into
that state and instead of going into that
state and leaving and then that's it.
It was a novel experience.
He went to that state and said,
I want to be in this state permanently.
What the fuck is this?
Cause he had, you know,
he's a trained psychologist and he's like,
we don't know what this is.
We don't have any maps for this.
We don't know what the fuck this
psychedelic experiences and all I,
so he was trying to,
when you went to India,
he was trying to see if this was a
state that you could permanently reside.
He wanted to stay here forever. That's
how much he loved tripping. You know,
when I come down quite often I'm like,
thank you God, I'm back to, you know,
stay zero ground. I
mean, he was like, okay,
let's do this forever.
They weren't fucking with him and
Timothy weary word like drinking from
drinking,
sipping viles of acids from LSD.
You don't know, are you so fucking
deep into the accident, so scary,
fearless, fearless, intrepid
explorers, but he, you know,
he realized that you go into that place,
you have this contact or whatever you
want to call it with some kind of either
hidden interior around or some kind
of exterior around that as humans.
Our perceptual neck.
Yeah man, that's a pretty scientific
way of looking at it. Realistically,
Interior Realm. Even being
just a conscious one, you
know, a consciousness realm.
You know the fact that those ideas there,
none of,
why are they not
available to me right now?
This is if it's all
generated interiorly yeah.
How come those ideas are not
available to be right now?
Do I need some intense stimulation of
different regions in order to give me that
information?
Like I don't know how the process works.
I'm not exactly sure if
other people know either.
I have the wound is fucking feeling that
when you take psychedelics or when you
take even marijuana that you are
part of what the experience is,
is you experiencing the
intelligence of the plant.
Part of it is it charged it.
It boosts up your own
senses into this weird,
crazy alien state and that's why being
high feel so like disorienting and feels
like you're almost like
not in your space anymore.
You're space is connected with some
other intelligence and this other
intelligence is showing you different
avenues of thinking. It's almost like it,
it,
it starts filling pores in your mind
and pushing you in a certain direction
until it wears off and then it wears off
and it's alien to your system so your
body gets rid of it
eventually and then it's gone.
It only has a certain certain
amount of love time inside of you,
but while it's inside of you,
it's like it's changing you. It's,
it's making you like
super fucking sensitive.
It's making me super aware and honest, you
know? I mean, one, a lot of people say,
well it doesn't need to be
where it just makes me paranoid.
Well maybe that's just
how you deal with stress.
Cause for sure you're going to get
moments if you smoke too much pot.
When we feel paranoid, this
is no, no, get away with that.
Everyone's going to have that experience.
But what is that really? Well,
tell you what it is, man.
It's like you're being,
you're being aware of [inaudible] the
shit in the world all at once and all of
the ship that you were hiding in the
back of your head and all the shit that's
though your worst nightmare,
that you're terrified that
you're actually manifesting.
Cause you'd think about it all
the time and when you smoked pot,
all that shit comes to life and on top of
that you're just disoriented. You, you,
it's, it's like surfing. It's
like surfing can be great.
Surfing can be like I watched those guys
when they look like they're having a
great fucking time and I go, God
Damn Surfing. It's like fine,
but you don't want stuff from,
doesn't look like fun.
When that wave comes over your fucking
head and smashes into the rocks and
pulverizes your bones with
a million pounds of pressure
and you can't get to the
surface. Well that's surfing too. Yeah,
we'll definitely roll your ass. Oh, you
don't know what you're fucking doing.
Especially if you fight it
and try to fight it at worst.
There's people that are fighting reality
every day and they often have like a
sort of a,
a fake map of the world that they've
devised in their head and that's how they
navigate. They navigate through
this fake map of the world,
but a lot of the little segments in
their mind that they have associated with
certain things and details and a lot of
it is delusional because you're trying
to protect yourself from your
own failures. You're all,
you know what I mean? Like,
especially with men, I think,
you know, we have, you know,
guys have these fucked up egos that are
designed to make sure that you have a
will to survive when a cheetah attack
sir or fight off a another tribe so that
you, your DNA stays in tack weld.
That is a fucking creepy thing,
just running around through your vans.
So
yeah. What were we talking about here
is what they call it, set and setting,
which is like when you're going to take
a psychedelic, what's your mind state?
What, what's, how, what's your emotional
state when you take the psychedelic in?
If you go back to the idea that,
what's his name? John. Mark Alegra.
What's his name? John.
Marco. Ron. Yeah, John. Mark.
All Allegro talking about early
Christianity was a mushroom called.
Can you go back and you look at the idea
of when you're going to take communion
or when you go to pray or when
you go to the sacred place,
you're supposed to um,
forgive your brothers
and your sisters because,
but so the idea is before you go into
a psychedelic state, you need to,
as much as you can,
work out this shit that you're avoiding.
Because when you go into
that psychedelic state,
anything that you're
trying to skip around,
any of those aspects of your personality
that need to be a level there,
needs to be balanced,
are going to spring out at you in a
million different ways that are really
intense. And if you're not prepared for
that, then you'll have the bad trip.
And the bad trip is you will loose Nate.
You can see little see crazy shit.
You'll look in the walls and see skulls.
Why are you seeing skulls? You know,
are you seeing bubbling skulls in the
wall where you're seeing bubbling skulls?
Cause that's what you're projecting from
inside of you because you're fucking
scared to death. You're scared to
die. You're terrified of letting go.
You don't want to, you don't want to, uh,
you took, your body doesn't want to die.
And then until you deal
with that initial thing,
then all these other neuroses will
spring up after that. You know,
your avoidance of reality,
all the different weird ways that
you're trying to avoid reality,
which is essentially just trying
to avoid coming to the grant,
to the terrain that you're on and
the terrain that we're all on,
his fucking intense. We're on a terrain
where we are going to go extinct.
And you know, who knows, depending
on how old you are, you know,
but and depending on how much technology
advances between like 70 and 10 years,
two years, one year, that's
an intense realm to exist on.
Um, I don't know. There's
a situation right now and
focusing on my, you know, the,
the whole thing with the,
uh,
the fourth reactor or they're terrified
that if any seismic event occur,
it's a zero chance of surviving
ascites seismic event. Right.
And we'll do and have another
blown reactor and we were
talking about it on the
podcast and someone made a clip of it and
put it on this website where it's like,
and people were like discussing this,
like this is a serious issue.
One thing was that I was saying was that
we're going to have spots in this world
because of nuclear power were for hundreds
of thousands of years it's going to
be dead wastelands dead and there's a
bunch of them and there's a bunch of more
plants out there that could
make a bunch more spot dead.
And this is just been less than a hundred
years we've been doing this and we've
already got three giant spots
where you can't go to anymore.
Have you seen like the places
where they store the nuclear rods,
they like have special places like caves
and they put it in and I believe that
they've, on the signs around the place,
they actually have like skulls and shit.
Everything's still on
case society collapses and
everyone forgets and thousands
of years past you go wandering up to
that place and there's this fucking skull
and you're you like, you just
recognize, okay, this is a cursed place.
One of the dumbest,
most brilliant ideas ever.
It's so dumb and so brilliant.
At the same time,
humans have a lot of Hubris and
it is a ridiculous one though.
We're fucking with something that
there is no technology to clean it.
There's no technology to turn it
into anything other than toxic,
lethal, horrible killing
shit. Yeah, it sucks man.
It's like the,
the exuberance of when that stuff
initially came out and people thought that
they discovered endless fuels sources
that exuberance like was everywhere.
It seemed like a real, it really
seemed like the most beautiful. Uh,
it seemed like we were entering
into utopia for awhile.
Did anybody ask them?
Like what happens when the power goes off?
Somebody who was like, dude,
you're being negative. Right?
It had to be like some sort of a stupid
argument where no one considered the
possibility that the power could go off.
You could lose both backup generators.
You have no other way of fixing those.
He just built a son,
felt a little tiny son and we were
just going to leave it there. That's,
that's insane. Well, yeah, I mean you
can't call it off. You can't call it off.
You can't. It's a demon basically.
If summoned the demon, the demon,
it is.
It really truly is.
Like you have some in the demon
when we have nuclear power,
if you really stop and think about that,
if there was some,
if a demon existed and in his very
presence he was poisoning the environment,
no plants could grow. I, and
that is a demon by definition.
And then when it gets near him,
dies a horrible twisted death.
That's a demon.
This is something people don't understand
with like a cult talk where people
talk about demons,
like so many demons and so many spirits,
they dig that shit literally. So they
hear someone saying, I, you know,
I'll invoke these things
to summon a demon.
And so then a lot of great
movies and been made after that,
the literal interpretation of
that. But every fucking day, man,
not just on a grand scale without so
many nuclear power, but in little ways,
people fucking summon demons into their
life all the time with no thought of how
to get rid of it every time. You
know, like when people shoot heroin,
that's something a fucking demon.
Like you've been told by every single
other like necromancer is someone that
demon,
that shit will fuck
you up. But people who do heroin and they
don't, they always start off with like,
you know what? I'm just going to do it
once. Just want to see what it feels like.
Everyone does that.
And then you fucking end up
under a fucking bridge with
three Cox in your mouth.
Oh, from, Oh,
from summoning this one stupid fucking
demon that is just destroyed so many
people and heroin demons,
a great word for heroin because it offers
you something because so many people
they say, oh yeah, fucking a Jimi
Hendrix. Love this stuff. Or, or,
uh, Elliot Smith, listen
how beautiful his music is.
You can go on and on about the people
who shot heroin and like made beautiful
stuff. So there is an exchange. I mean,
doesn't that kind of tickle around in
your head when he Bruce was blast and this
shit, you know, it doesn't,
it kind of tickled around.
You're like, what the f what?
Maybe what is that?
Maybe there is a little land,
like you rise up and see this landscape
that you can't see from the psychedelic
perspective
and maybe it's a, it doesn't seem to be
worth it. Whatever it is, I'll, I'll,
I'll look at it as like, what
makes you happy? And uh, I don't,
I don't see people taking heroin
and getting super happy from it.
Everyone that I've ever
known that did heroin,
the come down from it was
unbelievably bad. By bone jarring.
It would say your bones were,
that's how they would describe it.
Terrible drug.
You know,
you never see any like marathon
runners who were like shooting.
I had a friend who, uh, he was, uh, uh,
it was a good buddy of mine that lived
in New York and he came to visit me and I
didn't know when he was coming to visit
me that he was trying to kick heroin.
And then he was going to do is just
come and hang out with me at my house in
California and kick heroin with me.
So that's, I did not, no, I didn't.
I didn't know how bad he had it. I hadn't
seen him in a couple of years. So he,
he flew out and the dude was
just in bed sick for like six,
seven days. He couldn't go anywhere, man.
I would get him food and shit
and he couldn't go anywhere.
He came with me to work one
day I was on news radio.
He came and just sat around the set,
but he couldn't,
he couldn't move around. Man,
that dude was a, he was jacked.
It's amazing to see that,
isn't it?
It's amazing to see that traps that we
set for ourselves in the world that are
completely avoidable,
but for some reason we always set these
traps and then they smash on us and we
go through this awful period.
And then if you're lucky,
you get out on the other side.
That kind of goes back to
what you were talking about,
this idea of like having that near
death experience or having this awful
catastrophe happened in your life.
If you handle it the right way,
you can become a million times stronger
and back from that catastrophe.
People don't realize that.
So they're always putting off what could
essentially be the thing that makes
them happier than they've
ever been in their life.
Well, it's kind of a weird way of
looking at it. I mean, you can,
you could possibly be happy because
of a gastro or it could be horrible.
You could lose someone we love,
you know,
I don't think all catastrophes
and unnecessarily too great,
not great revelations,
but I think occasionally it can
give you an enhanced perspective.
Something that happens to you.
I mean,
the most interesting people that we all
know are people that have gone through a
lot of shit in their life. You know,
a lot of crazy experiences, you know,
know those,
the having to overcome terrible things
in places is sort of what makes them
exceptional.
That's right, man. But there's a,
there's a certain group of people who
liked to live pretending that catastrophes
will never happen to them.
Right. This is a ridiculous,
yeah.
The people that are overweight smoking
every day and I have a friend who is,
I guess he like 16 and uh,
he,
he smokes two packs a day and he'll
tell you when he's always like making
excuses. Like they've
even said no, that a,
it's all either you have
the gene or you do not.
So there's a lot of people that
will smoke cigarettes and never,
I'm in smoking cigarettes for
40 years. I am. I did the,
I wish I don't have the gene or I don't,
I have cancer. I went to the doctor,
my doctor says, you look
great, you look great.
The doctors looking at you and he's like,
you smoke how much a day?
And you're like two bags. And he's
like, you look great. You look great.
Get the fuck out of here.
When is he going to do to somebody
who's fucking intentionally poisoning
themselves all day,
intentionally poison yourself all day.
Not even just one pack. You
Glutton, glutton, nicotine vampire,
two packs a day, all day. Of course your
doctor's going to tell you what great.
You look great. Get the fuck Outta here.
I'm gonna see you soon though, bitch.
And then we'll be back soon and
we'll be back for some crazy shit.
I'm calling my uncle up, right? Yeah.
My uncle is an oncologist and then we've
got our eye on you. That's amazing. Yeah,
that's incredible. I never thought
I had a lot of money makers.
Smokers are for doctors. Well
course. I mean if you're a doctor,
you want your people. Well,
if you are a real doctor,
I mean it's obviously people
that don't operate for money,
you know the operate because they
love being an excellent surgeon or an
excellent doctor.
And you know,
we're not disparaging the
medical profession at all,
but if you were like some
money grubbing crazy doctor,
but there are a few of those out there,
right? Yeah, I've heard of them. Yeah,
there's every now and then there was some
money grubbing like Michael Jackson's
doctor. Dude, that
fucking crazy. Yeah Man,
I've got fucking fillings in my mouth.
Oh, they don't need to be there.
Cause my dentist, as it turns out
with giving unnecessary failing,
so I've got like,
I got fucking monster
kid. I just thought, I was
like, I just thought I,
I naturally was always getting cavities.
Oh my God. You know what I mean?
I was always getting,
I was getting blasted with fucking right.
Last Guy's ruining kids' teeth join
and the kids too and making money.
I hope he's in jail.
He's in jail.
No. What happened to him when,
when that scandal hit? Yeah.
That's not just fraud. I'm,
I'll beat the fuck out of you.
Drove holes in my kids had it didn't
need to be there because you're trying to
make money like that.
Fucking judge.
I wouldn't want to beat the
fuck out of that dentist.
Great to match his
fucking head. White. Yeah.
Imagine anybody that would do that to a
little kid. Yeah. Just to make some money.
Sure. That's a big,
this is something that,
this is a facet of reality.
So scary.
Imagine like what mine
state do you have to be in,
especially your fucking dentist.
You already making great money.
Like why do you need the extra dough?
Exactly. Oh what? I mean
how, oh Jesus Christ.
How can you justify that? That would move.
I would never sleep. I would have to,
however I have to find that guy in prison.
I might get a wasted just so I
can go to prison with him. Oh,
find out what prison needs.
Yeah,
I underground by now.
I mean if it was my kid, you know what
I'm saying? I mean I would literally,
I would want to get arrested and put in
a sell near him to so I could beat the
fuck out of him after he got arrested.
Yeah.
Well there's a lot of it just
wouldn't be able to deal with it.
Some guy with drilling and we're baby's
head to try to make himself some extra
scratch.
Yeah.
Cause we're asked to be a big shot at a
restaurant and buy a nice bottle of wine.
Is that what's going on?
Sure. Fucking asshole.
Yeah. I mean, who knows? But think of it,
I think to me is like that there was a,
a lot of people out
there who live like that.
Sure. There's a lot of people have
done, doesn't associate press. I mean,
you've seen the studies. There's,
there's been, you know, the,
I believe it was time magazine or someone
recently had some article about a new
book that's out there.
It was something like one in a hundred,
none of the hundred people
just fucking sociopath.
So remember the guy who recently went
rampaging through that kid's camp? Was it?
Where was it? Norway? Was
it your way? Yeah. Oh wait,
you went rampaging through that
camp? Just killing fucking, yeah.
And over there they don't,
they're not like the United
States don't have a death penalty.
So like they're giving this guy,
it's for a fair trial and they made a
big show of the fact that we're going to
do this. There's not going to be some
kind of a crazy visceral response to this.
And so in the trial, the guy, uh,
apparently is going into a
detailed account of how we
went walking through this
camp and shock kids who are hiding from
him and shot kids and how they tried to
run and how he found some of them by
thinking where he would hide if he was one
of these kids and he's enjoying it.
He's getting off on it
because he's a sociopath.
It feels good for him to tell the story.
So in these situations,
sometimes I think has passivism
gone too far in this situation?
The guy clearly shot a bunch of kids.
The guy,
why do we need to discover if his true
motivation or what his real crime was?
We know what the crime was.
There's a bunch of dead kids because
of this guy went rampaging through
sometimes. Don't you think you can
go too far on the side of 100%? Yeah.
Well, we'll live with the Dalai Lama
man. Dot. Randall seems like a great guy,
but he's never gotten
a blow job in his life.
We know it's a stupid wedding and he says
he doesn't know sex. Oh, he does. Yeah.
So is it doesn't have relations
and it says like, he sees it,
he's attracted to her, but he was
too much work. It's just, you know,
he laughs about it. That's,
but that's silly. That's silly.
You're missing out on a big chunk of
life. I think he's got some posey. Well,
I would hope so. I wouldn't hate him for
it. I think it would be a good thing.
But he's a month.
There's nothing. Yeah. But I mean,
isn't that like part of the whole thing
was the seller was saying the idea that,
you know,
you're beyond the needs of the flash.
Yeah. There's like the, I
mean, I don't, I honestly,
I've heard with Tibetan Buddhism that
there's some tantric sex that happens in
there and uh, and, and yeah,
we should probably
Google this, right? Yeah.
Is the Dalai Lama and the
Dalai Lama salivate. So all of,
I love to know that. Yeah. It
seems like an interesting question.
This keyword socks at fat duck.
I, I mean, I guess that I can
understand why monks say to be celibate,
if, if there's no more, if
it's not an ethical decision.
I understand like the complication
that can come from fucking people is
ridiculous.
Spectacular.
It's come flash durations like
lifelong can flag durations.
You can bring up being in the life.
Yeah, you can. It's a really
pain. It's a pain in the ass.
Yeah.
It's a pain in the fucking ass man.
He's not only supposed to be a
virgin. Yeah, he's a version. Yeah.
Well there you go ladies with
Dalai Lama's origin dude. Have you
heard about that glue in India
that you blast into your boss?
The clog up your seminar?
Yeah. You sent it to me. Yeah. And so at
that, is that what it is? It's load glue,
load glue. It's the new male
birth control that apparently uh,
not as permanent is getting,
have a sec.
To me it lasts between five and 10 years,
but they essentially just put airplane
glue or some kind of gel and deer.
They just pull you up so you can't,
you're just doesn't have the
fucking worms in anymore.
That's you're,
you're repurposing your loads.
How could that possibly mean
by your load smell like
fucking Zombie baby as well?
It's probably smell like rubber met.
Could you imagine if that was like the
beginning of the next fucking 28 days
later type movie? It turns out that
the shoot some shit and two loads and,
but it wouldn't makes a Zombie babies.
Yeah, but either way. Are you a person?
Good. That's a great harm.
Bites the doctor. Nothing.
The doctor becomes a Zombie Zombie.
Dr fucking furiously
attacks all the nurses.
They stab each other becoming to a
fucking puddles. Slippery a blog,
a bunch of Zombie fucking doctors
biting each other and shit.
All from one fucking Zombie baby.
Oh from one Zombie baby from one Zombie
low that was created by this crazy drug
in an Indian doctor.
Just a tornado of infection
spreads through the nation
from this one hot point.
Well we don't call in Dustin
Hoffman and her fucking space suit,
but you know,
he knows that he just had that
procedure done to his boss and he like
shot a load and to his girlfriend and
she's pregnant.
So like this is fence through the
movie is wondering if his girlfriend,
he's got a Zombie baby and her,
this is a great movie.
Great movie directors out there.
Let's just make sure
whoever made Trollhunter please contact
Trollhunters. Great. It's really
fun man. I know. I love that movie,
but it's a fun movie. It was the one,
the foreign one, right? One in subtitles.
Oh wait, no. I thought you were talking
about the worst movie ever made.
No, this is actually not that bad. It's
about a guy who goes and hunts trolls.
Does like rich, real live
trolls. The woods. It's a, yeah.
Oh, Trollhunters. Yeah. Trollhunter
yeah, it's really good. It's really fun.
And it's shot like found footage.
Yes, exactly. Yeah. Troll hunters.
That Beth was really good. It's a fun
movie or movies like that. Yeah, that one.
Yeah.
I love stupid movies, man.
Like I'm so looking forward
to the Avengers. So much so,
but I feel like I'm getting away with
something by being able to watch it. Yeah.
Like I'm 44 years old at a certain point
in time. I'm supposed to be past that.
I was supposed to be, you know,
interested in mature things, but I'm not,
I want to watch the Hawk fuck somebody up.
Let me tell you though,
that fucking idea of maturity
or how you're supposed to
act at some certain age.
What the fuck is that idea? Because the
way you're supposed to act is so boring.
Like it's basically saying just act like,
act like you're going to,
you're just a dying old piece of shit.
You don't like fucking super
insane special effects anymore.
You certainly don't like video games.
Kids with their music these days.
You go to bed at 10 you know like fuck
that. What it goes idea was that anyway,
that was just like a control freak.
Boring guys. Like this is how an adult rx,
yeah.
Well it gets to a certain point in time
when you compromise your thinking every
day. So much so for
work, you know, if you,
if you have to go in and everyday you
got to sell vacuum cleaners and you're a
dude,
I guarantee you there's some days when
you don't want to go in and sell fucking
vacuum cleaners.
You don't want to not swear all day.
You don't want to wear a tie, but
you got it. That's part of the job.
And so one of the ways to sort of
keep that going. Well you don't,
you're extreme isn't it?
Like the make the whole rest of
your life less extreme as well.
No more fun shit that need, you need a
sensible car. You can't drive a Mustang.
You know? You need to stop getting
drunk on the weekends. You've got a job.
Got to become SFW. Yeah. Safe
for work. Say for work. Yeah.
And that's why they were
allowed to drug test you. Yeah.
That's one of the most incredible things
that we've let happen this country.
Employers are allowed to drug test
their employees. That's insane.
The idea that someone you play,
you pay for a person's work,
you don't own their flesh.
You don't own them as a human being.
And especially when we're talking
about stuff like medical marijuana,
which is actually supposed
to be legal in California.
There's a lot of places where you
still can't get a medical marijuana
prescription.
You can't get an exemption and worked
for a lot of different companies. Yeah,
they won't. They won't have it. They won't
hire you. They don't want any products.
Yeah. It's a, it's a, it's a real
problem because with corporations,
I just learned this word and
I really fucking love it.
It's called diffusion of responsibility,
which is the idea that incorporations
their responsibility gets so many people
make decisions on things that
no one person's to blame.
Right, right. So, you know,
when the corporation,
somewhere in the corporation,
not everyone's anti marijuana,
just a couple of cots and
you don't know who they are,
but they got that in there.
They're all, you know,
at some meeting they just got it in and
where other people didn't agree with
them and they didn't speak up. That's
what's annoying about it. You know,
that this is coming from
just a few dipshits.
The majority of people
have no problem with it.
Fucking Nancy Polosi did you
see she came out against Obama?
Did you see that shit? What
she do? She fucking with,
she pointed out the fact that Obama is
busted more dispensaries than Bush did.
Wow. Cause she's pro medical marijuana
and she talked about all the help.
Oh and how many people are actually helps
in like what the fuck is Obama doing?
Why is the arresting all these people?
Yeah. When we voted on it, you know
diffusional responsibility as another
place that's used. Yes. That's an rape.
Oh yeah.
Right.
One person is much more likely to be able
to rape another person when there's a
big group of people around.
Yeah.
Because nobody knows who should act
first and everybody feels like it's not
their responsibility because
there's so many people,
you always got to act first.
That's the role. Oh, exact first.
If you see someone in the fucking street
who doesn't look like they're doing
okay,
stop and ask them if they're okay.
If you see somebody's car's fucked up on
the side of the road, not a flat, right.
If it's the first song be
well, if you go, are you okay?
And that fucking bitch leans over and
bite your arm in half and blood screaming.
You're screaming as you're
driving to a hospital,
you turn into a Zombie
and crashed into a tree.
Look man,
there's like a 90% chance if you see
someone on the street and try to help them
that their prior to the first Zombie.
It could happen.
It could be the other 10% hey man,
look,
I'm not taking any chances when
the Zombie apocalypse hits.
You don't want to be fucking patient.
Zero. That's what I'm saying.
You see a rape happening and you try to
stop it and it was just a dude trying to
rape a Zombie.
Well Zombie trying to up a dude.
That'd be a lot scarier because if like
gravy zombies were doing was raping us,
army go.
He's an idiot.
Why would you want to rape on Max the
next evolution of bombing cause we made
him right now will be raped. It's B. Yeah.
That's like ultimate fighting champion.
That's not bad ass enough.
You didn't need to be a Zombie raper yeah.
Have you ever raped a Zombie?
And the thing about raping a
Zombie as they'll fight hard,
but no one cares if you beat the shit
out of them and be like led zombies,
loosen the field and you could
just go beat the shit out.
No Dude, this is a sketch. I
actually wrote a sketch like this.
Promise zombies can
infect you, right? Yes.
How's that work? That doesn't make
any sense. Only 28 days later,
zombies can affect you. Well
know the biological. Yeah,
there's different,
there's different ex ex explanations and
the walking dead's got a really fucking
good one that I, it's the liquid
spoil a lot of shit to say it,
but there's a lot of different
explanations for it. That's really,
that's pretty cool.
The way that the creators of these stories
come up with like what it is, right?
It's, I mean there's no rule for
it. It could be anything. Yeah,
but it does in the walking dead. It's a
biological thing where in fact people,
but there's movies where
they come out of the ground,
so obviously that's not what's happened
though. Those are different ones.
That's like, I mean, which ones
did they come out of the ground?
That's return of the living
dead. Yeah, that kind of Shit.
I favor God. Yeah. Movies. Fucking it's,
you know why it was great cause
the zombies can fucking talk.
So remember they had that lady
strapped to the table. Spoiler alert.
They had that lady strapped to the table.
It was like a halfway.
Do you remember that?
And they're like,
they asked her because no one's
asked the Zombie. They asked her,
why do you eat brains?
Remember that? It's like, wow,
stop, stop paying off
debt. Oh my God dude.
Cause we never get to
really interview a Zombie.
I remember that now. Yeah, that's
right. They would call out brain.
Great. That's such a good, Ooh,
that was a great, I mean I was,
I was confusing that with
night of the living dead look,
maternal living dead is actually better
return of the living dead. I pop out of
Grapes of the living dead. As I recall.
We sit the opening of
night of the living dead.
Remember it's in the graveyard and he's
trying to scare his girlfriend and she's
like,
who's that man walking back there?
And there's some dude kind of walking far
away. This zombies couldn't walk fast,
right? And so we just Kinda ambles up
to the guy and like it throws him down.
The guy hits his head on a grave stone
and then she's like driving away in
terror. But we never know if that
Zombie emerged from a coffin.
I think that was somebody who is like,
I don't think, I don't think it, yeah.
First of all,
you're not going to get out of a fucking
coffin if you're a Zombie zombies.
They're already week 10 week.
Well the 90 little are all very nice.
We were living dead zombies week,
slow lumbering,
purely retarded.
So if you were like a
really good kick boxer,
you could probably like
keep a lot of mafia easily.
This is a lot leg kick.
It's simple moat as simple mode would fix.
Most of them say by you and you're fucked,
right? You're fucked. You're a Tommy.
Now,
if you get bitten by a Zombie years on
that night of the living dead as well,
that's not living dead
return of the living dead.
I think all of them share the idea
that if you get bitten by one,
you turn it into one.
Huh? I thought, hmm, but you had
to die. And some of them, oh,
when you come back as well,
I think in all of them or all of
them and living on 28 days later,
remember you just get one byte in your
frock. Remember when that chick hatched?
Did her boyfriend,
she machete one and he's like,
it was just a scratch and she
just fuck you and just boom,
boom with a fucking machete. She machete
dem in the kitchen. That was radical.
Remember that was such a good
fucking great fucking movie.
That's the greatest Saudi movie
of all time. 28 days later.
My opinion is the greatest cause.
It's the most original,
the whole scene where the guy wakes up
and he doesn't know what the fuck is
going on. That's really the same
scene that the walking dead is used.
They've used the same sort of thing.
This guy wakes up in the hospital and
he doesn't realize that the world was
turned to a fucking Zombie shit hole.
That's how do you get to do that?
Um, that's sort of the same
scene as 20 days later.
You know,
what I to we'd have to look into is,
which came first 28 days later
or the walking dead comics,
comics. So whichever came, well,
let's find out walking dead comics,
walking dead comics by them. If you
haven't, there's still fucking good.
How many years do you think they'd
been around for? I don't know,
but I like for a long time.
There's a lot of them and it's,
it's at the show is good.
I love the show and the show gets
a little too soap opera like,
but the fucking comics, they're just
brutal. And just if you, if you haven't,
download them to your iPad and by
him cause they're fucking awesome.
Mm.
It's Wikipedia.
Yeah. We're living in a fucking
beautiful time, man. Some guy, uh,
said something really recently. Uh, um,
I'll go look at it after
I figured this out.
2003 is what is a first issue
of the walking dead comics.
So now let's look up return
the living dead. No, no.
28 days later. Oh yeah, yeah. Sorry,
Tony. I think that was earlier.
I'm pretty sure, but I'm
just guessing. Let's see.
2002. Hmm. Ooh, it's
earlier sign of a bitch.
Yeah.
Well that's so close that it
might've been parallel thinking.
Yeah, I know. Who knows these guys.
First of all, it's kind of like,
if you want to make a Zombie
movie about a big apocalypse,
wouldn't a cool way to do it to be wake
up and, yeah. I mean, everybody's afraid.
You wake up and you're going to get up
in the morning and nuclear bombs had
already dropped.
You know what else it serves,
what purpose it serves is you don't
have to explain how it happened as you
started the big [inaudible] guy waking up.
So you don't really have to go into
the hall what ship proceeding it,
which by the way, I fucking
love dawn of the dead. Oh yeah.
Remember dawn of the dead and the
fucking news studio remember that?
And it's all falling apart.
It's just starting to fall the fuck
apart and people are trying to like
rationalize what's happening and swat
teams are going in and just blowing the
shit out of people and the all of
society is collapsing. I love that.
I like starting at the collapse of
society and then going into that post
apocalyptic state.
I hate movies that are the
lead up to the disaster.
We're like 80% of the movie is like the
lead up and then you just get 20% of
apocalypse.
I like fucking 90% apocalypse.
Well, what's a really cool movie?
Like, it's weird. It's very,
it's called Ponti Pool. It's a, I think
it's a Canadian movie and it's about, um,
these people that are, um,
they're, they're in a radio studio.
The whole show takes place.
The whole movie takes place in like
essentially one scene. It's one area.
It's all in this radio studio.
They're trapped in there while this
Zombie apocalypse is raging to their town.
Yeah. It's pretty fucking
cool. Fucking cool, man.
They're the people that were working
with them become infected and they're
trapped in the sound booth.
They realize that these things are blind
or they can hear you and they could
smell you. And they like trying
to get at them to the glass.
It's pretty fucking cool man. It's
like a real low budget sort of a movie.
But it was, I found to be pretty original
dude, if you know what I'm saying.
It's like one of those,
you want to watch something creepy.
That's why something creepy nights.
Yeah, that's it. If you've seen,
um, uh, the road or read the road,
do you that's the, uh, Hugo Vigo Morgan.
I watched that up until the point when
he was teaching his son how to shoot
himself in the mouth. And
I was like, check please.
I think the author of that
book was Cormac Mccarthy.
I think I remember the name of the book
was insane. But that fucking movie man,
to me that really captured what
it's gonna look like, if at all.
I'm sure that's what
it fucking looks like.
Just want people just
desperately trying to find food.
Cause even the walking dead like there's
trying to find food but somehow like
they always end up,
I guess they were on a farm in part of it.
They end up with some pretty nice
home cooked meals and people see,
you know people are like,
yeah,
people have like set ups
where they have big fences and
yeah,
and they look crossbar.
They've been taking vitamins and going
on a fucking treadmill they have because
they're actors but the fucking the road.
The road man.
Yeah.
Nobody looks good.
Yeah. It looks like they told him nobody
to eat for days before you shoot. Yeah.
Pale and stressed out and like man this,
that would be the way to do it too.
If you are going to be one of those
method guys and it was Gary Oldman
motherfuckers. Yeah, I bet he
would not eat for a couple days.
Yeah.
I mean you don't eat and you drink a lot
of fucking coffee and you lose a lot of
sleep and you get no a nice fatigued
state of stress because that's what it is.
That's what it's going to be like, man.
It's going to be fucking pure stress.
You're probably going to die.
You're probably going to get arrested.
You're probably going to
watch your friend die.
You're probably going to watch your
girlfriend get raped by some fucking super
powerful you would do
or just like fuck it,
and it's not going to be like the
criminals that you see on Mad Max,
they're going to be dumber than those.
It's just going to be dumb.
People who have power,
just dumb people with a gun.
That's going to be the problem
when the fucking grid shuts down
and it is entirely within the
realm of possibility. It's ignored,
but it's entirely within
the realm of possibility.
This is so fragile.
We have a house made of
toothpicks and tissue paper.
It's on the edge of a cliff.
Yeah.
In relationship to how our civilization
is set up and structured for longevity
in this incredible volatile galaxy,
and it's incredibly volatile solar system,
just the planet itself,
all the natural shit that
can go down and on top of it,
other done fucking shit that
we're doing like nuclear power.
Let me tell you something, dude.
People are fucking assholes.
Walking proof of that.
Go check out the dark ages.
Go look at what the Catholic Church did.
The RSPS.
This is where it gets crazy
about the Catholic church.
The Catholic church molested our
species when they were in their teens,
when, when our species was just
fucking getting shit going.
That Catholic Church came in and just
started torching people burning people,
killing people left and right,
wiping out entire civilizations,
all in the name of Jesus and all of this
from an interpretation of the fucking,
uh, New Testament, uh,
which is Pauline theology from
a guy who never met Christ.
And some people speculate, uh, the
real disciples thought he was a liar.
Call them a liar,
called the Paul Liar,
which is why when you look
at the pistols from Powell,
a lot of times he's defending himself.
He's like, I'm not a lot. I mean,
why would you say this to me? Because
the real disciples were like, hey dude,
who the fuck are you?
So he was like a late night
infomercial sales, right?
There you go.
Exactly.
And that shit got adopted by the Roman
Empire because they wanted to go to war
and they just were like, yeah,
let's use this. We can use this.
Let's figure out a way to make love your
neighbor as yourself and love the Lord
your God with all your heart,
mind,
and soul and to going into the Middle
East and stealing all their goal.
Let's figure out how to do that.
Oh, I know. Here's an idea.
I know there are events.
Let's go over there and kill the mother
fuckers and the name of the guy who said
don't kill anybody.
No,
I've had this,
I had this really intense series of
conversations with people about conspiracy
theories lately,
both pro and con like having Brian Cowen
and doesn't believe in any conspiracy
theory and Eddie Bravo who believes
in a lot of conspiracy theories,
but the most fascinating thing to me
is how many people will just blatantly
dismiss conspiracy theories like,
like nine 11 is my favorite one.
You cannot dismiss nine 11 as a conspiracy
theory because it was a conspiracy
that caused nine 11 from the
enemy in the first place. Okay.
Someone conspired some big event
and made some human beings,
made planes fly into buildings
and a bunch of people died.
That is a fact.
The idea that that no one
could conspire to do that.
It's ridiculous because it had to be,
it had to be a conspiracy in order
for it to happen in the first place.
It's a lot of people involved.
They had to keep their mouth shut.
They had a pass information
through in jpeg form.
They would fucking send things to each
other by sending each innocuous looking
emails with pictures in them and then
people would take those pictures and open
them up in in a program that would allow
to see writing in between the ones and
Zeros of the image.
Yes, and you might come up that. Here's
the thing, I always, it's pretty dope.
I always look at this shift from the
perspective of like whenever you get to be
in at any kind of corporation,
if you go to a high enough level,
you realize that people stop following
the same rules that everybody writes.
File it. Like, I can remember,
I used to work at this summer camp in
North Carolina, um, called camp panicle.
And I can remember like I went to,
I went to camp there too as a camper.
But I can remember at one point,
um,
I can remember at one point at being a
counselor and then like the people who
ran the camp came during the time when
all the kids are supposed to be taking
naps to my cat. I'm like, Hey, come on.
And then we went out in the lake and just
floated on inner tubes and I was like,
fuck,
this is breaking all the rules.
But it's the people running again
breaking the rules. So it's totally cool.
But that's tiny,
tiny Mike my sample.
But it's the same thing all over
the place up top where it's like,
look dude, don't worry about
that cocaine charge. Like, oh,
how much do you owe in taxes? Don't worry
about that. We'll take care of that.
Right.
Well how about when presidents leave
office and then dismiss a whole bunch of
people who these pardons
presidents are allowed? Like,
just give wide open pardon stuff,
gang of people for doing all
kinds of creepy shit. Yeah.
Why did they get to do that? You
know, it's a crazy rule. You,
you get to bypass the whole legal
system and they have like a list.
It's not just one person. Like
they have a, they have a personal,
cause there was a guy who was unjustly
cues and I think this man needs to be
pardoned and no, no, no, no.
It's not that. There's a list.
They get like 20 or 30 of them
or something crazy. Oh sure man.
How many do they get to a pardon? I don't
have it there. I'm just not that bad.
It's not bad. There's some fucking checks
coming in though, because I feel like,
I feel like somebody is abused
it recently. Like maybe Clinton,
how many presidents,
how many pardons does the president get?
Cause that would it be,
yeah, the guy. This keyboard
sucks. That's crazy though,
man. That is crazy. So yeah,
I think fucking conspiracies happen
because they happen in the smallest levels
of society. Why wouldn't they happen
at the highest levels in society?
Yeah, totally. Yeah, of course, man.
It's everywhere you go man.
People like are operating under the
illusion that politicians are honest or
don't like
presidents can pardon as
many people as they want
so they could pardon everyone?
God Dang, you were the president.
Like if Obama got pissed and went out
of office is the last attack he can be
like I'm pardoning every prisoner
in every prison over the counter.
Yo Dude sweat this.
President Clinton issued 456
executive clemency orders,
395 pardons and 61 confrontations between
93 and January 20th of 2001 President
Bush has 191 pardons.
Jimmy Carter granted amnesty
to all Vietnam era draft
Dodgers. Wow, that's cool.
That's pretty beautiful.
So Obama,
when he gets out of office,
he could pardon all people in
there for medical marijuana
dodged the draft in Vietnam.
Ted Nugent.
It's Kinda crazy cause just like he's
such a pro war guy, but there's a,
a depiction of what he did. I
don't know if it's true, but uh,
I mean he definitely didn't go to war
and now he's like super pro war as he's
gotten older pro or is it a weird
stance? Well, the idea of pro America,
I mean, look, if we really were
living in the game of Thrones,
you better be fucking pro America.
You know,
you better be like down for this one team
because otherwise some Dothraki horde
from the other side of the world might
fucking hop on a ship and come over and
Jack.
Yet it was very important back then.
But as we're connected by the Internet,
the idea of countries is
becoming less and less relevant.
It's all about local
government laws and the,
the whole world is one big
fucking connection. The
whole world is one big piece.
That's why all these people in
the Middle East are freaking out.
That the real rally and cry for
freedom is coming from the Internet.
That's how the use the Twitter and they
using Facebook to communicate with and
all that's all emanating
from the Internet.
Oh Man, I heard this thing
and I like, I never read it.
I think a teacher told me
this and I never explored it.
I'm sure I'll find out now though,
but it was this idea that about communism
and how Karl Marx said that real
communism was going to be a natural
evolution of society and a real communism,
not something imposed. Right.
Something that's just a natural,
obvious result of people getting smarter
and I'm understanding the way things
work
and calming it.
Money aids and a lot of things.
What it does is it gives you
an incentive to innovate.
It gives you an incentive to work hard.
It gives you something to show a score,
which a lot of people like to
see if you want innovation. Yeah,
right. I'm not, I'm definitely need,
certainly not a communist. I know,
I know you're not, I'm not, I'm
definitely not anti money, but what, what,
what I'm starting to see happening is
that the more that you work and like
little collectives with people, the more
you help the people around you, you know,
as much as you can,
just the people directly around you,
the more that group rises up and succeeds.
Right.
And this idea of the new form
of like podcast networks,
which is where you have like, um,
like, uh, like, like my friend,
he's doing a podcast network
called feral audio and ideas.
It's just a group of people that are like,
uh,
plugging in together and like sharing,
sharing profits.
This is the new model of things.
It's a collective, right?
Artists and people. Yeah.
You know,
I mean I'm not sure if the podcast world
represents a microcosm of the entire,
no. Well No, no, no. So here's the
thing. This is what's beautiful
about,
and this is why I bring it up
is a new thing.
The reason that it's the reason we can
do podcasts and the reason like you,
like you just shot your own special on
your own and the re like seeing comedian
shoot there on, on special honors because
we have more access to technology,
right. Then we have before and
technology shrinking, eating smaller,
which is basically creating a situation
where collectives form instead of the
pyramid Illuminati,
top down power structure where
someone owns the equipment and gets a,
the majority of the dub.
Do you know what I'm saying?
It's like everything's shifting,
widening out, spreading out. And that's,
that's why these fucking
tyrants in the Middle East,
it doesn't work when people
have information. Right.
Doesn't work well. You know,
I've always, I remembered, uh,
when they were talking to Muhammad
Ali because when I was a kid,
I remember when he had gotten, um,
when he had a fraught Michael Spinks,
it was on television.
It was like a big deal.
I remember my parents were trying
to explain to me when I was a kid,
like what had happened did,
they'd kept him from fighting.
Like my parents wanted to see him fight.
Let my,
I can't believe my parents
were into fighting at all,
but they'd want him to see Muhammad
Ali beat Leon Spinks. Yeah,
there's like some
important fight and there,
there are dealers at this
guy was like a cultural hero.
Cause what he had done was
stepped up and said it,
why would I shoot with a guy in Vietnam?
No Vietnam man ever did anything to me.
And he's right. And he was 100% right.
And everybody knew it and it made sense.
And because of that,
they punished him and they wouldn't let
him box for three years. Right. You know,
they took away his livelihood in the
prime of his career. Like physically.
Yeah. His, well, this, that, that
phenomenon that you just described,
it's been going on since
the history of chocolate.
I've top down power structures.
I, this book I'm reading
now, I can't run the name.
It's so fucking good, but
it's got, um, uh, you know,
a picture of Copernicus standing
before like Catholic hope's,
um,
and being judged for talking about the
fact that the earth revolves around the
sun.
You know,
it's like people say the truth throughout
history and many people have gone to
jail or going to burn it. The
fucking state for it. Yeah.
Oh,
that's true.
I think the last time I drank this
energy drink, it's pretty mellow,
pretty mellow for an energy drink.
It's like a lot of it is natural.
It's like the 12 in it and shit.
These guys sponsor, you know,
it's just a friend of mine,
Ryan White, powerful. I'm
right. My friend Tom Atencio,
he, uh, used to run affliction and he
was the guy who put together the, or,
or one of the guys who put together their
mixed martial arts cards that they had.
And I always appreciated that. But he
did that and they, you know, affliction,
support MMA.
So I became friends with him and I was
wearing their shirts for a little while,
but then they fired him. So I
quit. Out of respect for my friend,
I avoided my, uh, my
partnership with them. So,
but so he sends me soda now. He's cool.
He's cool as fuck. He's a good dude.
I just really respected what
he and his company did for MMA.
They really supportive a lot of fighters.
They, they um, they supported a lot of,
uh, of uh, fighters by promoting,
um, they put on actual shows.
They had I think three big shows,
you know,
and some of them were fucking great,
great fights.
They put together some wild fights,
but they just found out
it's way too expensive.
People don't realize how much money
the UFC spends behind the scenes,
like how much it costs to keep
the machine running. It's a,
it's an amazing amount of work.
There's so many people
behind the scenes and they,
all of them have a long history and
the UFC has this big name, you know?
It's hard to fuck with that. It's like
to try to make a rival football league,
even if you have a lot of talent. He kept
van. Everybody knows what the NFL is,
you know? They tried that shit a
couple of times. They tried to,
with the XFL member
was like Vince Mcmahon,
the wrestling guy and tried to do that.
It's hard. It's hard to get people to,
you know,
and the UFC is consistent with the
getting the best talent consistently
get the best talent. What's her
name? Oh yeah. Ronda Rousey.
The girl who walks around with a number.
Oh area.
You're like, hey, I got a perfect face.
Perfect. Her face is just, she's
a flawless face. It's like, wow,
what's really funny about watching her?
And she's gotten down this casual wave
to the hordes of pervs. He wears screen.
It's like an apocalypse now
by the sea,
a testosterone. She got this little
side like two finger wave like God.
Do you remember that scene? That was a
great fucking similar apocalypse now.
That was, that seems so real. Totally
real man. If you'd ever seen it,
what happens is these guys were over
there fighting. It war its own men.
There's thousands of them.
They fly in these playboy playmates and
they were like dancing around on stage
and it just gets angry. It's, it's just
a, it becomes like a mosh pit of gorillas.
I know.
Eventually they have to
ended and fucking fly out of there.
That was one of the best.
I want to get left behind that
scene. I don't remember. I should,
I don't remember.
Can I ask an important question?
I think a lot of UFC fans wonder
this every day and me included Eric,
what's her name?
Does she have a boyfriend?
I do not know if she currently
has a boyfriend. I do not know
what we're dying to know because we
all feel like everyone has a shot
bombed on buy.
I can't buy print it bombed down by
the Rothchild. She gets bombed out.
That people who like transforming to a
rep telling in front of her here take a
diamond.
She wouldn't do this, but if she wanted
to she wouldn't. But if she wanted to,
she's the type of check tick and
get some like Middle East King,
fly her out for like 1 million bucks.
Easy. Yeah. Easy million bucks a night.
Fuck him for 10 million. Yeah. I mean
when you, when you have a choice,
if you have 1 trillion bucks,
like,
well from what I understand is like royal
families that have so much money and
there it's not, they're not, the money's
not public. Like when people look at like,
who's like the richest man in the world?
Oh, it's Bill Gates as it's probably not.
It's actually probably some
dude in the Middle East.
It doesn't talk about it at all. And
you don't know. Some prints are like,
they have extraordinary amounts of money
and I don't think that a lot of times
it gets measured up in the same pile.
I might be wrong about that,
but from what people have
told me about like, like real,
real wealthy people in the Middle East,
there's some of the wealthiest people
on earth is that it's like insane,
staggering amounts of wealth.
So fun.
The thing I like to think about is like
maybe you know like when you walk by a
school and you see all the
kids playing in the playground,
some of them are fucking
playing like four squares.
Some of them are running around playing
tag and they're just having a blast.
Sometimes I think maybe
that's what society is.
Maybe you were just like kids playing
around in this playground that's been
created by really,
really smart,
super wealthy people and kind of watching
watch maybe like maybe they have some
fun with us.
They like throw shit in there every
once in a while just to play around.
But there is so fucking powerful and rich.
They're not,
they don't need to go in there and like
seem like they're famous or act like
they're magical. They just
like to watch. It's fun.
Every once in a while they'll
throw in something crazy. You know,
every once in a while they'll
throw in the aids virus or toss it.
Well, boom. Have power for no reason,
which essentially everyone at the
very top of the, the heat pads Po,
there's no reason why you
should have power. Okay? Now,
if you have power for s for no reason,
you know that it's not like you earned
your power through your basketball
skills.
You know the fact that you shoot us a
wicked three pointer or you are awesome at
the violin.
No,
there's no real tangible skill that you
present that anybody else couldn't also
have.
You know what I mean?
What is vague characteristics
like leadership and intelligence,
the ability to speak well.
God Damn, there's a lot of
people that have bad shake.
Yeah,
there's,
there's thousands of people out there
in your neighborhood that can do that.
Okay.
So they know that you have to be
treacherous in order to retain this power.
When we see different laws every
day that it'd been brought up,
like the National Defense Authorization
Act, all this on the different stuff.
All when you see like civil liberties
giving you a road and you see corruption
that he wrote,
there's your evidence that that is the
exact evidence that you need to know that
the people better in a position of power
shouldn't be empowered to trying to get
more and more and more control. Why are
you trying to get more and more control?
Why are you actively trying to get
control instead of dealing with the issues
that we already have? Dealing with the
crime that we already have dealing with,
you know,
are unsolved murders or what have you.
Instead of devoting your time into that,
into that aspect of helping society with
law instead that you're trying to take
away civil liberties,
you trying to erode people's freedoms.
That's the purest sign ever that the
people who are in a position of power
shouldn't be in a position of power.
It's really sad. It's pure, it's pure.
There's no arguing, there's no
denying it. Obama can never deny it.
If he brought it up to him,
there's nothing he could say.
There's no way anybody could
save for your own good.
When you did take away your ability
to send a private email to somebody,
we can't.
You can't have that.
Well,
what they say is they inevitably,
one thing that they'll always
say is it's complicated.
It's a very complex system.
You don't understand.
There's a lot more to it than
just legalizing marijuana.
There's a lot more to it, Joe. It's always
complicated. Vampires love complication.
They love tangles and complexity and the
opposite of simplicity simply because
they, you know why? Cause
they fucking hate the truth.
And the truth is always simple. The
truth is always just a very simple thing.
It's a, you know, you jump off a
cliff, you're going to die. It's,
if you fucking don't eat, you're
going to be hungry. There's just some,
it's a tweet. The truth is a
tweet. Yeah, fucking vampires.
They will take a truth and they'll
transform it and extrapolate so much shit
from it that it turns into a fucking lie.
And then let's say, you know, we can't,
it's just too tangled up the world's
economies just too confusing.
This is why we've got
to exploit these people.
This is why we've got to throw farmers
in jail. Cause it's complicated.
This is why we're at war. We can't
just not go to work. It's complicated.
It's always complicated.
But in the, in real life,
it's not complicated. There's nothing
fucking complicated about, uh,
you probably shouldn't throw bombs.
Places where there's kids that's like,
if you see somebody throwing bombs
in a place where there's some kids,
you're gonna be like, you know,
you probably shouldn't do that.
Fucking kills kids. But like, when it's
no one knows what you don't understand.
There's a target surgeons,
surgeons can be in that. Oh,
you mean fucking farmers who are sick
of you driving tanks through their opium
fields? Is that the insurgence
you're talking about?
Are you seeing your original video
from Wiki leaks? Right. The, the,
the cash collateral murder
video with the chose the,
the helicopter shooting missiles and shit,
and to a car that has kids in it.
Oh yeah. You know, and
someone says, this kid's well,
it shouldn't have been taking the kids.
What were they carrying guns. I mean,
and whatever the fuck they said,
you know,
you shouldn't have any kids with you
because if they should have thought about
that since they're the enemy, they should,
uh, meanwhile they were innocent. They,
they shot a bunch of innocent people.
It was, it was a complete total cluster.
Fuck.
Sure. It's not complicated. It's
a real simple thing about why,
if that's the thing, here's the
thing though, isn't it simple?
There's some simple ideas.
Yeah.
You're not supposed to shoot
in the cars that have kids.
You're not supposed to shoot in the
cars. I have kids in them. And also, uh,
if you send out good energy into the
world, you give good energy back.
Here's another basic principle that you
can test all day testing next week. Just,
well, they didn't even like
zoom room to see if fair,
if the people do have guns
that they mean they, they just,
they just Gundam down, man, I got to
have that ability and that kind of power,
you know? And they're like, I,
you know, and they're saying, no,
we were pretty sure this guy's got a
gun and this guy's got a gun and they're
like a permission to engage
and they get permission.
They just fucking open up on
these people and that's it.
Those people don't exist anymore and it's,
it's,
if we wouldn't even know that that
is happening and we don't even know.
Have you seen the new video,
the Blackwater video that's
been released recently,
now the young Turks had
about him? That guy sank. Um,
I really liked that guy show. He's,
he's, uh, he's fucking fearless man.
He attacks everything.
He attacks, uh, like,
like he goes after that Peter Schiff guy,
you know Peter Shift when he starts
making excuses for Wall Street, you know,
the way to fix this. And he's just
like, no, you use it and calls him out.
And he's like, you just want to keep
extracting more money from the system.
You just want to keep
exceeding, know you're talking
bullshit. And he cut him off.
I liked it, man. It was interesting. But
he was talking about this and he was,
you know, he was talking about
how, um, what was the fucking law?
Yeah.
What was the law that was passed?
Which one?
Shit,
I'm completely lost my thought.
What was his fucking thing about the
young Turk? Yeah. I didn't see it.
Shit. God dammit. Well, I'll,
I'll remember in a moment. Let's rewind a
few steps back. All this macro shit, man.
Thinking about the macro,
the conspirator to drive me crazy if I
don't remember what this fucking gods
video was about. Oh, are
Rakhi. Oh, Jesus Christ. Oh,
this is why it's so disturbing.
I'm probably trying to forget it.
It was watching the
blackwater guys this young,
the young Turks made a video about
this and exposed it and showed there's,
there's more videos had been released
that were like from the actual cars of the
guys in black water that we're driving
around smashing into people's cars.
One of them,
they hit a lady while she was walking
across the street and you see the guy,
see the lady go down and go, oh
shit. And they just drive on.
It just left her there and they're
smashed into people's cars.
They're sticking their guns out the window
and just randomly shooting and things.
It's right. It's really fucking crazy.
It's really crazy to watch Matt.
It's really crazy. And
that's enough. That's just,
there's just no getting around
that you can't, you know,
you were talking about like making the,
that the Catholic religion or any kind
of crazy cult that wants to have some
sort of a justification for doing
something wrong. You're fucking wrong.
We'll read you some huge,
huge volume tome on why it is that what
they're doing is the correct move for
everybody else in the long run. When you
show a video like that, is that correct?
Move using mercenaries, man. How
could you see how crazy this is?
You got people that are willing to kill
people for money and you're paying them
a fuck load of it and you're letting
them just run a no man. I mean,
this is a,
this is a problem that will always exist
as long as power structures are trying
EULAR instead of circular. And, um,
and there's no way around that man.
There's always just going to be that.
There's no way around that.
And the problem is when power
structures are triangular, they don't,
usually the people at the top of that
fucking triangle, the pyramid, they don't,
they won't listen to logic. They don't
care about what's right or what's wrong.
They're not going to listen to you.
You have to take the power from the right.
That's what the idea of the fucking right.
Well they have to die off
too. That's the, that's how,
yeah,
let's hope they die off because it's
been a few thousand years and they don't
seem to be going anywhere.
It's just going to take different forms.
They put on different masks and
admittedly the violence is lessening and
lessening. So maybe the violence will
dissipate two to nothing. I just,
I had no idea,
man.
I've been reading this fucking book
about what the God named Catholics did.
Did the fucking Cathars is what
they were called Wikipedia.
That thought has just got exterminated
by the Catholic church is burn at the
fucking state man for,
for uh,
believing a different version of
Christianity. It could have been a threat.
Well,
this is a long time ago obviously.
It's just amazing that in 2012 after all
the time and all the supposed to shit
that we had learned from the dark ages
and today even still you've got this
video released,
this blackwater video of people just
going to a foreign land and just fucking
people up. You know it's the, that is the,
at the very,
the very peak of our society when it comes
to like causing change and damage and
that is like the highest,
most impactful part of our world is war,
right?
Most as far as like destruction and as
far as like that's like society at its
breaking point or its boiling point and
it seems to stay at that same level.
It seems to stay at that same level.
We're,
we're always just that close
to fucking everything up.
We're always that close and like as good
as it ever got was like when Clinton
was in office, didn't really seem
like we're going to run anymore.
Seems like the Soviet Union
kind of falling apart and
we're the only big dog in
town were pretty cool and we're not
going to fuck with anybody money.
So let's just, you know, it felt like
everything was going to be okay. Yep.
But then it went right back up to its
boiling point and you realize that boiling
point where we had with the Clinton
way important, that was unusual.
That was unusual. The lack of threat of
imminent death. That's the unusual thing.
This normal thing.
And we've gone through with the Bush
administration and we go through with the
Obama administration now that's,
that's unusual.
That is rather the norm did the unusual
thing is peace. The unusual thing is,
is prosperity and relaxation and not
worrying about fucking bombs dropping on
overhead from the other side of the world.
Well
it's, yeah, it's definitely normal one,
the people who are making the laws and
apparently then paid off by people that
prosper from or it's totally normal then.
But it's amazing that it's, it's, it's
still pushed through. It's amazing.
It's amazing that in this day
and age it can be so obvious.
It can be so laid out and yet
still gets pushed through.
Here's what it's fucking amazing.
What's amazing is there's somebody
in a corporation that has to have war
happening or they're going to go bankrupt.
That's what's amazing.
There's people who like, man,
we gotta get some wars do it. Or
our division is strictly
missile reconstruction.
We're not blowing up missiles and then
we're not reconstruct the areas where
missiles destroyed. Yeah,
that's it. Yeah, exactly. Dude.
That's what they're thinking when they,
when they hear that piece might be coming.
That's like,
that's hearing that a fucking, uh, to go
bankrupt. Do you think there's calls like,
Hey,
oh,
I heard that y'all are running a surplus
on a certain muscle that we're about to
go into construction on it.
We don't want to come out with version
two while y'all still got version one
going around and you think you can make
some campaigns where you could put those
bad boys to use. Do you think that, uh,
I was like a fucking Robert Downey jr
contractor character could call somebody
up and ask him to launch the missiles.
You know?
Do you think when that was the
sons of bitches and manufacturer,
that Shit Watch more footage on the
news. They're like, Oh hell yeah,
that's a bean. That's my boy. That's
my, that's the child shredder.
Hell yeah. Look at that thing. Look
at a spread on that bomb. Hell yeah.
Every time they see that they're
like Ching, Ching, Cha Ching.
Every time a bomb goes off they're
like, yeah, that's a hundred grand.
Hundred grand. Hundred grand. Yeah.
What about dudes that are
like never been to war,
but they're like obsessed with like
soldier Fortune magazine or on protection
fucking, you know, packing
heat ever where they go. Yeah.
They live in the wild west in the back of
their head. Dude, I gotta tell you man,
I think I got the potential to be like
that would be his man. Cause like I, yeah,
cause I like it's an equalizer.
That's why people like it. If you,
if you feel like you've been put in a
situation where you could have been in
danger physically because some asshole
wanted to fuck you up and they could have
done that to you, you know, that's
a terrible, terrible feeling.
So once you've experienced
that terrible feeling,
you only have some sort of an equal,
nothing wrong with it, man. I really,
I mean it seems so weird cause I know
I come off as this kind of like hippie
dude,
but I was raised in the South Man and my
dad taught me to how to be safe with a
gun. Taught me off on it was the
shoot a gun taught me like, you know,
it took me hunting and like
I'm not afraid of guns.
I think they're fucking awesome man.
They're really cool. I just don't, I,
I haven't gotten around to buying one,
um,
in La and not if it feels
like there's this, you know,
we were talking about this around
Diaz and he was saying like,
it'll attract guns.
Like it's a lot of people think that
they think that if you have the weapon,
it will act as some kind of magnet
for negativity that will like bring,
bring it to you. It's a superstitious
idea, but some part of me, oh my gosh,
it may be so a man. Right? I don't know.
Maybe I should just ignore it and I have
a gun because I mean, I, I, I can't,
I doubt anyone's, well, you
never know, man. You never know.
Somebody could just decide to
fucking kicking your door in,
like take your shit and
fucking stab you to death.
People do get robbed. There are home
invasions. People do scope people out.
It doesn't happen. Doesn't
happen that often. Well, the,
what's really going on, man,
is it, there's so many
fucking people on this planet.
You're hearing about so many different
violent acts. Even in bad neighborhoods,
violent acts are fairly rare. No. Well,
it might be a million people in one
of them gets shot a day. It sucks.
You wanted a million. Not a lot. I mean,
it's not, it's not a little, you know,
when you think about it that way,
sexy, this is the society we live in, man.
This is where we've hit
upon in the multiverse.
Cause like he got all the other things
that people can break into your house and
do like what a great dimension where
like fucking hot chick sometimes swarm
neighborhoods and just give random blood.
Right?
Well what if you don't want a
random blowjob from a hot check?
What have you trying to like control
your sperm and you're on this Dalai Lama
type journey and some hot chick breaks
into his house and sucks his dick and
ruins this whole spiritual journey.
Yeah.
What if you turn into a Zombie?
Like anyone's not going to
want a blow job from a high.
He's going to realize that he wasted
his whole stupid life dressing up like a
genie when he could have been just
getting his dick sucked from the get go.
The lesson yet is a good lesson. But you
can't force someone to have a lesson.
Well, you can't rape the Dalai Lama.
I mean, that's what she'd be doing.
She'd be waving the poor guy.
He couldn't help himself testing that
hot chicks going rape the dollar.
Why am I want a woman that
hot stove stroking your cost.
You are not even in control. You're not
even in control it. You're a Zombie.
You what you are in Dna Zombie.
You just trying to shoot DNA brains.
You're just trying to shoot loads loads.
Just trying to get rid of that.
That ache in your balls. Oh,
what a terrible Dalai Lama.
The whole guys like means he's
a single sort of pudgy man,
kind of Asian character,
has a lot of really famous friends.
You know it's kind of a name dropper.
Always hanging out with Richard.
I'm not dissing him at all. I'm just
being honest about is what it looks like.
It'd be awesome if you would
that would rock is fucking world.
If some Megan Fox looking chick came
in and started talking to his cock,
that'd be awesome. Is that the
Dalai Lama fire back at you? Well,
you got mad at me. I don't want, I don't
mean any disrespect to the dawn wall. No,
fuck you Joe Rogan.
Oh would be crazy if I was the first
cattle Dalai Lama told to go fuck himself.
Like wow,
I must be a deck.
I'm sure he's a great guy and I don't
think there's anything wrong with doing
life the way he's doing.
I just think it's when I,
when I look at his life in comparison
to a wife that I would find interesting,
I'm like, come on man. No, no, you don't
want to have a wife or a girlfriend.
You don't want to have sex.
You don't want to like willing,
don't want to engage in like fun
things and really is that too much?
It's too much of an effort to,
is that,
is it really too much of an effort
to have a relationship or can you,
can it be managed and you're just a lazy
bitch and you can't figure out how to
manage your own life and manage your own
relationships in a way that you would
attract someone who would also have sort
of a harmonious relationship with you.
You know,
for some people that's like too much work
to try to get their own shit together
to attract someone.
So I mean it's like a,
just a real complicated formula so to say,
oh that's too much work.
I think you miss out on big part
of what it is to be a human being.
He obviously has compassionate
relationships with people
where he's friends with
them and he communicates with them.
But to not be exchanging affection,
in my opinion,
is just this massive misunderstanding of,
of the the joy of life.
Because sex with someone you love,
that you're really attracted to you is
one of them that you really attracted to.
It's one of the most intense physical
experiences and beautiful experiences a
person can ever have. It really
is. It's an intense, it's,
it's a beautiful intense experience
that cannot be recreated in a solo
environment.
Well this is that.
This is the thing I like.
It's these are things that are impossible
to answer because that you could,
I only read about them.
I don't know if it's true or not,
but like I think a lot of people who
become hermits and leave society of those
people, of all the people who
leave society and become a monk,
go and become a hermit, go into the woods
and vantage from life, all those people,
probably a big percentage of them are
doing it as an escape mechanism. Right,
right, right, right.
But I bet there's a small percentage
and then the that are like have heard of
these peaks that you can climb too and
consciousness that the certain things
will get in the way of getting to
those peaks. It's not impossible,
but certainly it's kind of like no,
you know,
there's a lot of different paths to do.
The florist,
some of them are more difficult
than others and some of them are,
especially when you've got
the complication of the wife
and children, you can't,
you can't go through some of the,
uh,
forms of discipline that apparently
are required to hit a transcendent
experience that a lot of
people, many, many, many, many
people have written about.
You know what I mean?
So I think there is a small group
of people who really authentically,
you're just like,
I don't want to fucking go for it.
I want to see how far I can go and
do this is their enlightenment,
is there this state of higher awareness
that you can get through meditation?
I want to do that and that,
you know,
the prescription for some of these
things is the fucking meditate for years
straight. Yeah. You know, you
can't do that with fucking kids.
You can't do that with a,
you can't do that with a job.
You can't do it with the normal
complications as society.
So you got to go out into the,
out under the fucking cave to do it.
Just amazing.
When you really stop and think about it,
it's like no other or rather it's
like any other discipline, you know,
in order to really take it
to the highest level. Yeah.
You have to devote all of your time to it.
That's it.
And managing the mind in managing the,
the deep recesses of your consciousness
and increasing the brain's ability to
focus on certain tasks and things.
And then they've shown that
that meditation directly
changes the way the brain
works. Do you know it's the,
the, the, the, the, the rose.
Um, uh, what would it would,
it would, vision isn't with,
they use when they're doing like cross
sections of the brain during any sort of
a neural activity, cat scans, I don't
know if it's a cat scan or whatever it is.
They run tests on people and they find
out like what areas of the brain are.
Secondly,
they have
remarkable minds. You know, people
that meditate like Buddhist monks,
it's like they've literally
developed a different sort of things
brain dude, it's, I don't think
my brain is changed, but my,
one of my favorite parts of the day,
I wake up in the morning and chant,
I fucking love it dude.
And I'll tell you,
I'll wake up with my brain's squirming
with shit thoughts and like anxious
sometimes and just maybe I had a bad
dream or like I'm stressed out about
something, right? I sit down and fucking
meditate. 10 minutes, 15 minutes later,
it's not gone. Yeah, I'm not healed.
I'm not cured if the thoughts,
but now the thoughts aren't on top
there underneath my will. Right.
You know what I mean?
And that changes everything for the
rest of the day because now when I'm
attacking the different problems
and things I have to accomplish,
the first thing I'm feeling is this sense
of self control and underneath it are
all the anxieties instead of approaching
your problems with an anxious mind or a
turbulent mine.
I think managing the mind and
putting the mind to good use,
it's just like managing the body
and putting the body to good use.
And I think the mind can
become more athletic.
The mind can become more synaptic or
more responsive rather synaptic weight.
Well the, it's uh, yeah, the mind is
definitely, I'm sure. I mean look,
when you write,
don't you notice that if you like
take time off and write again,
you start writing and you'll feel a little
clunky at first and then after a day
or two and the groove and then,
yeah. And then you get to that,
it's like you have to like
keep up that sort of shape.
You have to keep up a certain
creative shape or you know,
or a mine, uh, you know,
a meditative, sort of a controlled
shape. This is what people, yeah.
Um,
this is the product.
This is why more people don't meditate
and more people fucking boring.
It's boring at first. It's boring
at first, but when, but after you
lose your mind after you lose your mind,
after you fucking get past
the initial thing, the
initial, like boredom of it,
it turns into something really incredible.
Yeah.
But he's the deepest you've ever gotten
through meditation. Yeah. Man,
the deepest I ever got through
meditation was I was super stoned.
That does not count. Oh, it's
the wound is here. Right?
Most certainly you can get stolen shit,
man.
Yeah.
You get you.
It's one of my favorite things to do
as it get stoned and meditate. Fuck,
that's the best man.
We kinda had this funny story about,
or this funny analogy about Ufo abductees
is that the real problem with any
stories about that you
ever hear about Ufo is,
is that you have to automatically discount
every one of them that involve five
grams of mushrooms. Well, it's
true too, right? Because you, oh,
you were tripping dude,
but made me, that's no, but
maybe that's how he sees it.
Yeah. Well no, fuck
or maybe like a lot,
a lot of different philosophies came
from people getting really high.
That's that book I showed you.
You know that cannabis is, has,
it is a very old plant that we've had
a relationship with for a long time and
people love doing validate things that
you thought of when you were stoned.
They lost and validate
states of consciousness you
attain through merging with a
plant mother. But I'll tell you, man,
fucking getting hot chanting and,
and uh, getting high. Wow.
That's like now if you want me to
like come up with a time when I,
when I wasn't stoned in meditating.
I do think of a time when I was on the
zen retreats sitting and staring at a
wall and for like seven hours straight.
And like definitely there was a shift
in consciousness and I was like getting,
getting confused. I take,
I take offense to that.
I really do.
I was getting confused because I've
been staring at a wall for so long.
I was getting confused about my identity,
which was sort of a consciousness.
Yeah. It was a bit of a
poisoning, but she like,
well, I was staring at the
wall and I knew I was, I mean,
we're talking like eight hours and
fucking meditating. Malik's yeah.
With your eyes open, like you're just
kind of going in and out of like,
no,
you technically you're not supposed to be.
This is why in the Zen temples in
Japan where the people really take it
seriously,
people walk around with fucking rods and
the moment amongst starts nodding off.
They get a nice fucking rod and the
right on their shoulder, you can whack,
wake your ass up. Wow. So like, um,
and that's no,
they want you there in the moment and
you're trying to accomplish, well,
super,
she mentioned
the only way to become like
a real warrior. It could
become a psychic warrior.
Well, this is the fucking
crazy thing man. I mean with,
with what's a zen monk trying to
accomplish the answer to that? Nothing.
It's like a but, but um, yeah,
but other people who don't have such
lofty ideals to merge with the nothing is
uh, these people are trying
to accomplish things.
And I believe the name of these super
powers or magical traits that you get from
disciplining the will are called
cities as I d, d, h. I. S.
Yeah. And these are like, these are
like the ability, if you, if you,
if you start focusing, you know, I
would even say that in some weird way,
stand up comedy is a form of city in the
sense that you're able to get in front
of a group of people and
make them fucking laugh. Uh,
and it takes a long time to develop.
It's a discipline that takes a long
time to develop. And you get this skill,
it's kind of abnormal that some people
aren't able to do. You know what I mean?
Like it doesn't have to
be reading someone's mind.
It doesn't have to be levitating or
walking through a wall. It's just like,
shit man. When I watch the fucking
UFC and see somebody do it,
flying leg kick and to someone's
head, that's magic. To me,
that's a magical fucking thing. That
guy, the fact that that guy can do that,
it's acrobatic or when
they're these fucking asshole,
not they're not really assholes,
but when you see him getting
our backflip content,
these guys throw a fucking
back flip like it's nothing.
We're fighting for three rounds and
handed the backflip doesn't land and you
fall.
That's going to be played on the internet
or at least get involved in that back
flip. It's super extreme man.
So to me that's also a four.
It's not real magic in this instance.
Explain, explain, explain it.
But it's like I think that people have
can develop other forms of this and the
other forms of it.
I don't want to use the term telepathy,
but maybe people get really
good at reading micro
gestures or micro movements in
someone's face and recognizing when
they're telling the truth or when they're
telling a lot,
fuck man.
Just someone who's really focused and
sitting and listening to you and looking
you in the eye and a really
focused way that's a nerving.
Sometimes when someone's got real
fucking focus, cause most people don't.
Most people are scattered. They're
scattered to the fucking wins. Man.
Barely listened to you for four minutes
without fading out or checking their
phone or fucking,
you know what I mean?
So we'll itself just the ability to draw
your senses and in focus in the moment,
that's a pretty potent
thing to be able to to do.
And you're not going to get
that from playing video games.
You're going to get that from
getting drunk all the time.
You're not going to get that
from fucking all the time.
You're going to get that from
stopping the show, sitting down,
crossing your legs,
taking a breath and not moving for 10
minutes and watch your mind freak the fuck
out. Your mind will turn into a cat.
You're trying to put in the bathtub.
Your mind will just start
wriggling squirming, warming.
Hey, what are you doing?
That's almost the first thing
he's thinking like, come on.
What are you fucking doing here? What
are you sitting here not moving forward?
What is this or you think you are?
Thank you fucking Gandhi.
What do you think you're doing? Really?
You're gonna do this. And then that.
If you overcome that,
then that'll change a little bit and
all of a sudden you'll start relaxing a
little bit. Your body relax and all
of a sudden it's like, Oh shit man,
I haven't put that fucking
candle out in the other room.
I should go put that candle on the other
and I think I left a candle burning in
the other room. And then you just breathe
through that and then it's going to be,
oh fuck. I called Jack, I forgot
to call Jack. It's all these,
these moments trying to take you away.
It's almost like your mind is set all
these infinite traps to keep you from
getting in the state of stillness,
but eventually the more you do that,
the more your mind will begin to be
in the moment and not be in a place of
expectation and not be waiting for the
meditation doing and not be thinking
about how cool it is that you're
meditating or out dominoes that you're
meditating. Something else kicks in
that thing, that fucking thing, man.
That's the thing that I think people are
trying to extend through their entire
lifetime.
It's just that state of being present
in the moment with no goal for what's
going to happen, not caring
about what happened. You know? I,
it's just a difficult place to get to.
You don't always want to be there either.
You don't want to be there
all day because you have to live with
humans and if you're going to live
completely in that total zen state,
I guess he could do it.
Ron doss style and just go video
conferencing with people all day online.
But if you want to actually
try and make a living,
no,
the ROM dot.
Stout is really interesting because
there Ron Bass style doesn't have ethics
attached to it. Man, that guy
fucking talks about going and eating,
like going into a fucking restaurant
and ordering a steak. Yeah.
Fuck yeah. Steak he did in this story.
I don't know if he continues to eat me,
but it's like his whole thing
is like, listen man, it's
not worth what we're, well,
what we're going for here isn't fake.
A fake way of fake and position.
What we're going here, it for us or going
for is this being in the flow of life,
being in the moment, wedding it. Sometimes
I'm in total fucking cheeseburgers.
Times eat that Burger. Sometimes
it needs fucking, you know, uh,
get your cock sucked sometimes. You
know what I mean? Sometimes it means,
well,
you said that was so southern and your
docs up North Carolina and my sister's
room,
I love my southern accent
does come out sometimes, but
yeah, man, it, this is this,
this state of being in the
moment doesn't mean, right,
right.
But don't you have some sort of an ethical
responsibility for animal cruelty and
the pollution of the environment and
all the different variables that really,
even though you have no control over,
you are a part of society and yeah,
the macro contribute to the
problem by continuing support.
This is what I think about that.
I call this the what you're saying.
I consider it the starving kid in Africa.
The starving kids in
Africa has stopped many,
many people from experimenting with
like bringing their will end the world
because they think, yeah. What about
the fucking starving kid in Africa?
What about the,
what about the macro?
What about the eating meat
hurts animals and um, the big,
the bigger picture where I think that
that is a very valid thing to think about.
But I think the first thing to think
about before you start thinking about the
bigger picture is your little picture,
right?
It's thinking about how are you
treating the people around you? How,
what living condition or un,
how are you healthy?
Are you exercising first?
Deal with that.
Deal with that and then worry about the
fucking kid in Africa first deal with
that thing and you'll get your, you know,
your, your, uh, get your focus back.
Come out of autopilot first because
your ego will tell you like, look man,
we've got to think about the big picture.
The Ego always wants to think about
the big fucking picture. Do you go?
Holly's wants to think about like,
if the ego is a messianic,
the ego wants to be Jesus.
The Ego wants to heal the world,
or the ego wants to fucking do
all this crazy shit. Meanwhile,
you're fucking smoking cigarettes.
Your apartment smells like cat litter.
Your falls are fucking
festering with crab lice.
You know what I mean? You got to
fucking think about the fucking money.
You got to think about the moment.
Yeah. We were talking about
a dude who was screaming,
yelling about chem trails while
I was smoking cigarettes. Yeah.
It's like what you're doing,
how's gotta be worse than what
they're doing by spraying you?
Absolutely, man. That that's
you. This is the beside.
This I think is the recipe
for a true revolution.
The recipe for a true evolution does not
involve going out into the world trying
to attack these ancient,
powerful monolithic structures by
throwing Molotov cocktails at them.
It fucking involves stopping looking
at the way your treating the people
directly around you. How do you treat
waiters? How do you treat people at the,
at the cash register? How do you
treat people that you have power over?
Even if the power's illusionary and it's
just a game cause when you're with a
waiter, you're playing the
game of someone being served.
They're playing the game of the sir.
You're just fucking people,
but you start looking,
how am I treating the people around?
At first you start looking at how am
I treating myself? That's number one.
Number one, look at yourself. Are
you being authentic to yourself?
Are you being sweet to yourself?
Are you taking vitamins or
you being cruel to yourself?
Are you poisoning yourself?
Are you shoving poison into your body's
first bodies body first deal with that.
Then once you start feeling
good and healthy again,
the depression will start wearing off.
And then you start looking at the way
you're treating people around you.
Then you start tipping too much. This
is something you've taught me, man.
I don't want to go all fucking
secret on everybody's ass here.
But ever since I started tipping too much
fucking more money than I've ever made,
it's been coming into my life,
dude.
And I feel like there's some
kind of like direct, uh,
correlation between how much you put out
and how much comes back. It's possible.
It's also possible that just came
in a coincidental time doing.
You started making money and could tip
because had some momentum running. Dude,
I'll tell you,
I'll tell you one number one customer.
I'll tell you one quality that is,
I always have when I'm broke.
You know what that fucking
quality is selfishness.
I always will look at the way I'm acting.
It's always very fucking selfish.
It's always survival mode and I got to
look out for me. You know what I mean?
This is, there's a fucking verse and
I always quote the fucking Bible.
I'm not a Christian,
but there's a verse in the New
Testament that I'd always perplexed me.
It was something like those who have
will get more and those who have not more
will be taken away. And the idea
is like this sense of like this,
it doesn't make sense. It doesn't
go with the way we've been taught.
It doesn't make sense that if
you give out more than you have,
you'll get more back. It doesn't
say you just have to be generous,
give more than you have,
more than you have to give more than you
can trust with
my children. If you just say I'm going
to try a hundred percent and 10%. I know,
I know. You're right. No, you know what
it is, man. It's like the, the church,
uh, had this idea and the
idea was typing, right?
And the idea was give 10% of
your income to the church. Right.
This is so because the church Churchill
deal with like giving the money out.
Now I think that this is based
on a metaphysical principle.
I think it's based on a
metaphysical principle, which
is that, uh, if you give out,
like imagine, I think we may
have talked about this before,
but imagine if you cut out
10% of your income and,
and just put it in a pile and made the
decision that that 10% you're going to
just fucking give to people in need it,
you're just going to
give it to help people.
You're going to use it
to like help people.
That's 10% of your income is going
out into the world to help people.
That would be your favorite money.
That fucking 10% like on a Saturday.
If you get to go into that
account and be like, fuck man,
I'm going to buy my
friend Xbox just because,
because that's coming out of
the 10% that's a cool thing.
That's a good idea, man.
Everybody thinks it's like,
oh,
I'm going to go give a ham
sandwich to a heroin addict. No,
go fucking surprise your friends.
Take them out to fucking take him out to
dinner and then fucking buy dinner when
they didn't expect it. Take
one of your friends, right.
It doesn't have a lot of money right now
and do something really cool for them
when they don't expect it and don't act
like they, oh, you do swag now. I do it.
I just thought it'd be fun.
That's fun. That's tightening.
If you ask me instead of letting the
church be in control of it. Yeah.
Well the problem with the, the church is
always going to be like, who are they?
Let's, this is people, man, they're
not really representing God,
so he got a good church. You can
work out well, could they? You know,
there's a lot of churches that do a
lot of great stuff for the community.
There's a lot of churches
that keep people together.
There's a lot of people out there,
dude,
they didn't haven't thought
too much about the world.
They haven't thought too much about the
complexities of the various different
things that we do
understand about the world.
Subatomic particles interacting with
each other across the university.
The exact same time trek communication
through subatomic particles,
particles that are in both a super
position when they're in a state of both
standing and moving at the same time.
Is this too much craziness going on
in the world and there's not enough
curiosity and that combination of that
and their culture and whatever the fuck
their genetic imprint
was, whatever, you know,
whatever nine volt battery that they
were born with, all of that combined.
Some people need religion, man. Some
people, it's like a super beneficial tool.
I don't, I don't deny it. Look at the,
essentially what Christianity
is supposed to be.
It's supposed to be someone about
being positive, about representing God,
being booed, living life
by God's standards. Well,
if you look at what God's standards are
sort of vaguely and you'd take out of
this story is about killing
people and he tells you to kill.
And what happens if you're a gay dude
and Jesus doesn't say any of that,
but it's in the Bible.
It's supposed to be the,
if the Bible is supposed to represent
the word of God, if it is reeling,
well this is the shit.
Talk to the fucking loon
land disciples saying right,
you can't just throw up cry.
Sandy got that whole sweet old book.
Ultimately when it comes down to a Chirsto
really depends on who's running the
church.
Like the church could be a great asset
to a community and a good place where
people learn to be good people
or it could be fucking craziness.
If you wind up in a church where you
know the priests are fucking kids and the
whole thing is chaos,
I'll tell you, you know what,
I got a lot info from man.
I got a big download from when I used
to go to a ga paid church with Reverend
Michael Beckwith. I would fucking go
there and that guy would last positivity.
You would go there and get, you would walk
out of there feeling so fucking great.
What is a,
his denomination?
Uh, he, I don't know the
name of the and denomination,
but like he there end into
this book called the science
of mind by Ernest Holmes,
which is like this idea that you create
your own reality by the thoughts that
you think. And I know
it's a, it's just uh,
it's that mixed in with all the world
religions make stand with like kind of
like, I mean, listen man,
it's a big church and I'm not saying
every moment of the ceremony wasn't
slightly embarrassing and I'm
not saying they're not people,
they're dressed in like baggy big baggy
pants and wearing sandals and have
really gone deep into fruit land.
I'm not saying that that didn't happen,
but that church man, some of the
information I got out of there,
it was fucking really
high tech information.
I'll tell you something else that happened
to me there and I'm sure I'm going to
get fucking made fun of for this, but I'll
tell you, man, I had a fucking terrible,
I'd throw my back out,
throw my fucking back out and couldn't
move my fucking neck and I was like
fucked up. And in a lot of
pain and I'm standing there,
oh my God,
there was a song you sing.
Never seen this song and
this fucking guy behind me
retard giving you a back
rub and grabbing your shaft.
I know there's a story
before you attack the fucking you
gotta let me finish it early in the me.
Here's the reason I knew
this was coming. I know.
Sorry,
I fucking
this guy.
I think it's funny if this
guy touches my back and dude,
instantly I felt fucking better.
Instantly. Everything went away.
My back felt better.
Everything
you gentlemen remember
what I said yesterday about
disinformation agents? Dunkin,
clearly we just expose himself as a
government agent agent if disinfection.
He says all this brilliant shit and
then he incorporates some vacuum magic
touches because motherfuckers
doing Christian heels
only report from my own experience.
What about praying the gay away?
Have you ever seen anybody
successfully pray the gay away
now? Have you ever seen
someone try? No. No. Okay.
I haven't seen anyone fucking pray.
Hey Lane,
but it's not the same thing.
It's all the same thing as a guy coming
up and touching you and hearing your
back didn't come up with
some magical touch.
He'll get back.
Silly Bitch, why didn't you give
me this? I can't. I can't tell.
Leave this alone.
This is ridiculous.
So some guy came up and like that'd be
his desire to stick his penis inside.
Your asshole was so strong,
but as he touched your back to jolt,
just realign your back because your back
knew that it had to fight to survive
because they're all felt the love and
lust of this man's fingertips. Sterile.
You'll me
Dale have flannel underwear on. He wasn't
wearing underwear that, whoa, look,
I bill I, I'm s rock Cockins
zipper. I'm dangerous.
Right? Pressed up against the
cold metal resemble. Yeah.
I believe that your
attorney healers and always
let me just touch his back.
The gay came out of his hand like a
lightening bolt and was like one of the
Avengers.
The gay came out of his hand,
India back and it just popped
your back into order. Hey listen,
this is exactly what Jesus said was like
a baby. I'm being persecuted. I you,
you know what you, and this is religious
persecution and yes, it is. Absolutely.
Absolutely. Like I prayed
it, he, he got out, he
couldn't help himself.
You were sexy,
was slightly slumped leaning to one
side liquid, get a hurt knee, navy.
Trying to remember the,
perhaps even limping,
trying to remember the song that we
sang there just so I get your anymore.
I think I did. I'm going to give you
more. Okay. More fucking ammo. Okay.
La,
go read God's power.
Something my life.
I can't wait.
And they would just sing this over and
over again and everybody was really
getting into it.
People would like go up and down the
aisles with Kleenex because people would
start crying and like it was like,
but you know the,
I've learned to not throw the
baby out with the bath water. Uh,
and so like a lot of the stuff, yeah.
I don't know if I necessarily was like,
you know, fully on board, but I got
some good information from there, man.
There was like some really,
uh,
the shit that he talked about was this
concept of being able to like at your,
you decide when it's time to, to be
happy. You decided to not be a victim.
You decided to pull yourself out of the
negative Meyer that you're in and you
can just do it.
You don't have to come up with excuses.
You don't have to go to the fucking
mountains and meditate forever.
You don't have to, you can just
stop being a victim. Right, right.
And the moment you do that,
your life will become a million times
better and everything else will follow
from there. You know, you'll start
treating people around you better.
And when you start treating
people around you better,
you're going to get more
prosperity because if you're
treating people around you
like, Shit, yeah, you're cutting off
all these currents and circuits that
well,
you,
any interaction that you have with
someone that ends up in a negative and
negative on their side or a
negative on your side, you know,
it's going to leave you with like a little
bit of a deficit for sure. You know,
it's not a good feeling. So a good
feeling when someone's upset at, you know,
it sucks,
sucks fucking sucks.
And you don't realize how
much of an impact your,
your words or your actions can really
have until you see them someone,
and then you realize then it's
all manifest itself to you.
It all shows and you're like, God
damn it. What the fuck was I thinking?
I just got so flippant. Yeah. You know,
being rude or being aggressive or being
adamant or argumentative or whatever it
is that causes these blips in the matrix.
But sometimes you need to have those
in your life. Just as a reminder,
you know me, careful, you know, not even
saying that you should have to have them,
but you look, I, I've seen, I seen him
in other people and I learned, well, it's
ping pong, man. You can get
caught up in a long game and shit.
Ping Pong young people and it's like,
look, there's no way that you're going to,
there's no way that you're going to be
perfect and there's no way you're going
to avoid conflict and there's no way
you're going to avoid getting angry.
But the main thing is,
man, here's the main thing,
forgiveness and forgiveness.
If fucking isn't always fair.
That's the thing about forgiveness, dude.
It's not always fair. You're not out. He,
it's not always about who wins or who
loses or who's right or who's wrong.
Sometimes you just have to be like,
look man,
we got fucking blasted out of a
pussy or plunging towards oblivion.
We're in this insane fucking dimension.
You freaked out for a second.
I freaked out. I forgive you. You
win if you, you know what I mean?
Like you just take that extra
step and you know what that does?
That stops the fucking, uh, what,
when you see like that stops the, the
negative energy ball. That's the idea,
right? Um, are you talking
about anyone in specific?
Yeah. Yeah. You know, I,
I already,
I know you already did with for people
to know Brian and Duncan had gotten into
an argument and uh, you
know, it was unfortunate.
It's unfortunate on both sides as
unfortunate that Dunkin brought it up in a
public setting and sort of blind side.
And I'm going to think you feel that,
right?
I set it on that last pass.
Yeah. Did I did the real,
here's the real thing I learned from
it though, man. This is the thing, you,
you're not going to avoid conflict.
And in a community,
that's one thing I learned is we
have this little fucking commodity.
Do you,
if you had a chance to do it all again,
you wouldn't have done it that
way. Absolutely not. Yeah.
I'm going to be honest with you.
And Maura was snippy that day anyway,
my name even got snippy with me when I
was fucking with you and I was not being
not aggressive, but you, you seem
like you a bit testy that day.
Yeah, man. I was texting you that
day and, and what happened was, um,
without going into,
I hate fucking resurrecting it again
because I think that it's like, um,
what made you test you that day?
I don't want to talk about that man.
Okay. And that's a personal issue.
It's a fucking personal issue.
You certainly have, there's a
family issue or a bit imbalanced.
Yeah. But anyway, there's no excuse. I
don't fucking know why was I testing,
always test me cause I was not
in control of my fucking self.
That's when anyone's testing,
there's no excuse. Right.
People always come up with excuses for
acting like a fucking asshole. Right.
It all boils down to like
you handling your own shit. Yeah. Not
imposing your own bullshit on. Yeah,
exactly. Do it. But, so
the what, what happened is,
um,
so what happened is during a podcast
and Atlanta with Marshall Child's the
laughing skull, I was
starting to talk about, uh,
it was videos I made for
south by southwest because
I was trying to lead in to
talking about the
Moontower comedy festival.
Well when people don't know,
Dunkin has been pretty adamant about the,
uh,
in my opinion,
the very correct idea that if you're
going to have a festival when you profit
off of it and you have comedians
perform at your festival,
at the very least you
have to fly down there.
I mean if you want them to work for free,
you can't really expect
them to fly themselves.
And then when you find out the whole
thing was sponsored by an airline,
you're like, what? Right.
Cause they are going to profit by
the fact that people have to fly in.
Like the whole thing is
crazy. So you, you wrote this,
you made this video where it was Hitler
and then over Hitler's screaming you had
the handle translation. The Hitler
meme. Yes. The translation was saying,
you know how preposterous it is,
right.
It was just the basic idea. What
you said, if you charge for a,
if you have an event centered
around Comedians, artists, whatever,
that couldn't function without
the comedians or artists,
you have to fairly compensate them.
You have to pay them,
pay them a percentage of the door.
It doesn't have to be a lack,
give them a little cut, whether
it's a flight hotel, I don't know.
Whatever the fuck it is.
Right. Just like make it fair.
So I was starting to talk about that
and then Brian got on the microphone and
started talking about how no, no, no, they
pay the performers. Whereas like I have,
you know, I said it was up to
the venues. Well No, no he, he,
what he was talking
about was as a comedian,
you can get sponsorship from other
people like Brown paper tickets or other,
like corporations will pay for you to
perform at their parties or will in some
way fund you.
But the festival itself doesn't pay.
So some venues don't pay.
The artists know.
Some venues don't decide that because
they're at a certain place in your paid.
Cause.
I've heard that some people have gotten
paid by south by southwest who's getting
paid.
I have,
um,
I actually think the Guy Charlie said
tello who runs south by southwest.
When I was at Moontower, we had the same
fucking conversation. Right. And you know,
like you, he was, he was saying, you
know, we don't, we don't fucking pay job.
We didn't pay Johnny Cash. Whoa. You know
what I mean? Like we don't pay. Yeah,
I know. Watch, you know, like
gangster, he was saying, yeah,
yeah. Johnny Cash to work
for you for free. Okay,
sir. All right. So that's the point.
I already had this conversation with
this guy right about this. So I,
at least from the perspective
of the representative of
south by southwest in the
comedy side, it told me directly
this happened. And then also as a,
as an, uh, um, as a, uh, uh,
other note, he said, you know, we,
we do give a hundred bucks. Well,
we don't even talk about it.
So they pay comics 100 bucks.
That's what I found out. That we don't
talk about it. Yeah. That's what he said.
He said, this is not going to, I
didn't bring up Charlie's to tell them,
by the way, when there's a big secret, we
were given a comic, a hundred bucks. Yeah.
Whatever. It's still so the, so, um,
and Charlotte to tell it seemed like a
really nice guy and I kind of respect him
for coming up to me and
talking to me about it.
I still completely disagree with him,
but he came up and he talks
because he heard your video. Yeah.
He's the one who does the comics
or south by southwest. So like,
it was really cool.
He wasn't angry.
He just came up to me and broke it down
in his own way from his own paradigm
about fucking work. So anyway,
justification for not paying.
You get a lot out of the festival
as a performer. It's, it's,
there's two paradigms. The paradigms
are, the two paradigms are, uh,
people who pay based on a percentage
from the door or some other form of like
money compensation and people who feel
like they're offering a venue and they're
offering the benefits that you
get from performing on a show,
whether it's working out or HR were
amazing. The idea that, you know,
you could have a festival of art and the
a profitable festival art and say that
the festival is more important that
the art that's represented there.
So the festival should profit.
But the artists are getting the luxury
of performing pimp gangster festival and
a lot of it's really amazing.
I like to play my own devil's advocate.
South by southwest is an expensive
festival and a lot of people like seeing
bands and some comics like seeing
bands and we're going to go to south by
southwest anyway, so now they don't have
to pay the 700 bucks that you have paid.
They see everything.
So there's that.
There's the justification of that
perspective. I've never been,
but regardless I feel, when is it? I
don't know. You know, we should do,
we should just book the Cap City if
it's not already booked probably.
I bet it's already booked a,
but it's like something like Doug Benson
or someone tries to get like even Vance,
I'd be really fun cause it
doesn't Doug do all that shit.
He goes to all those places. I
don't know. Yeah, he's always,
he's a wild bachelor character.
He's out there slinging Dick around
the country for 20 in the afternoon on
Saturdays. He's doing what he wants
now, man. It's really fascinating.
You know he's got,
Doug's got,
this is this thing where he can
show up at like a regular club,
like it has a full weekend and he comes
on at four 20 in the afternoon and he
does these for 20 shows where it's all
his fans. What about side Boob? Sunday.
How'd that guy manufacturer that where
it gets checks to send pictures of their
side tit. Who's this? Who are you
talking about? Doug Benson does that.
It's the best side boob.
Sunday. People tweet,
beautiful hippie chicks tweet.
They're like the profile.
That's beautiful.
Some,
it's really funny how you look on Twitter
and some a porn girls have like pick
of the,
and you
click on it,
it's done with a giant Dick in their
mouth and one their ass and you're like,
whoa. Really? Just picking
the day. That's it.
No fucking morning at all.
Like you got to go, okay,
well now I know how she's walking in.
There's some girls don't ever
have that in their Twitter. Some,
some strippers might
as well be accountants.
They might as well be working for Denny's,
you know, they just have like, you know,
here's today, this is what I
did. I built Dah, Dah, Dah.
But some, uh, some of those,
uh, porn girls have, they'll
just throw up some wild pictures.
You've gotta be NSFW gotta be careful that
when people get mad for probably,
well,
does that work thing? That's what
we were talking about earlier. Well,
I mean it was sort of, I mean, we
didn't even really dove into it.
What happened was Lou and this elevated
snippy state, I'll just cut to the chase.
You called Brian out for something
that you believe that he was doing
incorrectly with how he was
putting on a comedy show. And uh,
he defended himself and got very upset
at you and couldn't believe that you set
it on here. And he was really
hurt and stormed out of the
room. And then, you know,
we sort of were sat around and talked
about the importance of comedians getting
paid and whether or not that was the
right thing to do and what the real issue
is. And you know, it's uh, there's,
there's a side to be tad on
both men's point of view.
Brian's and yours,
you know,
there's a side to be had on Brian's
about the way you presented it, did it,
you did it like when you were in this
elevated state and you were responding to
him questioning New Year in the south
by southwest thing and you attacked,
some people don't know this just to
make sure people know I told Marshall
knocked to upload. Yeah. Okay.
I know you're not trying to just do not
trying to make it more than it already is
and Brian is a very upset
about it and you know,
his side of it is that he did pay some
people and there's a lot of expenses and
that he had to pay for taxes and he's
paying for the rent to keep that place
open. And you know, to be honest,
he probably to bit off more than he
could chew and he didn't realize how much
was ree was involved in not just putting
on a podcast where you just being the
producer of the podcast, but also
running a comedy show at the same time,
calling people, booking in, having the
community and show up, put them on,
give her a flyer, trying to get people to
come put tweeting it, making a big deal.
It,
it's more involved.
It's not like those guys that like do
comedy juice or something like that.
There's a lot of work involved in that.
There's mailing lists and there's,
you know,
I get their milling this all the time and
they're constantly emailing me all the
time asking me to come and perform. Like
they're, it's a business for these guys.
They, they, they're trying to, you
know, there's a lot of work behind it.
I think it got away from him and he's
corrected it and he's corrected it now.
And because of this confrontation,
the good that's come out of it is that
the money situation has been taken
completely out of his hands. So he doesn't
have to worry about that anymore. Yeah.
Which is cool. And my shows can
still pay for the rent. Yeah.
Here's what's not cold. And this
is the thing it taught me. Um,
cause I've been seeing
this in the positive thing,
thankfully in my life mostly.
But what happened was, even though
it didn't get uploaded at the time,
it could have, Marshall could have been
like, fuck that. I'm not the leading that.
That's good. That's going to battle.
Get traffic. That's good. Right.
You could have been an asshole.
I didn't know where I was totally wrong.
Shouldn't have brought
it up in a public ward.
I shouldn't have brought up in a public
way. I was totally fucking wrong.
Even if I felt like Brian,
uh,
confronting me about south by
southwest was wrong. What I did was,
so if Brian was throwing a
negative energy ball my way,
I grabbed that negative energy.
Bob Expanded it and tried to stuff it down
his throat out it. I didn't feel good.
I was angry. Right, right. And so then
Brian got mad and then the energy ball,
he explained to exponentially
increase the energy ball by, uh,
having a blowout and saying,
fucked up, getting Trostle. Okay.
He doesn't do well when criticized anyway.
But my criticized like that
in a very confrontational,
confrontational manner on a podcast. Yeah.
It's very upsetting for him. Right. But,
you know, he didn't react
to it. So it was a boat.
It was bad reactions on both
sides. Neither one of you
guys reacted and verbally,
you know,
if you wanted to look back at yourself
and how that whole thing went down,
you know, where you're going back and
forth to each other. Were you okay?
I didn't go. That's the thing, man. I went
back, I went, I went back at him once. Oh,
I apologize. On my podcasts
and I guess I'm gonna call it.
Yeah, we're good. You did.
The initial words that you used were
very confrontational in Atlanta. Yes.
Yes. But then how you launched
it off was very, dude, you look,
use the words ripping off
Sarah being off. I said, Robin, I
said, Robin, even worse, I said,
he's robbing comedians and that's the
fucking wrong word, uh, for not paying
people. And you will go back and you
listen to it. What do you get out of it?
Have you listened to it?
No, I don't want to fucking listen to it
cause it's anchorman. Righteous anger. I,
I,
I can only on my side of the street,
my side of the street when I
attacked him, I was pissed. Right,
because you felt that he was incorrectly
correcting you and then he was putting
his 2 cents in. Yeah. In to an argument
that you have. It's a very big one.
It's not just about south by southwest,
but it's about a lot of
other organizations who
don't pay the performance.
Exactly. And I think that the tides are
shifting now and I think that that, uh,
paradigm where you charged money for a
shower and don't pay the comics is going
to hopefully be gone permanently.
Uh,
because what I really liked about the
south by south west video is that it,
it, I think it encouraged some
comedians to start speaking up.
And I think artists are very afraid of
confrontation and are afraid of speaking
up about, uh, things that
are obviously right now.
Here's the time to speak up and there's
a time to not speak up. And I think, uh,
with Brian when I,
I said,
you're robbing comics that wasn't
coming out of some altruism,
you know, uh, state of wanting
to like be Gandy and how fucking
comics that was coming. It's like, Oh,
you slapped me, I'm going to slap
you back. And so that's wrong.
That's wrong action. That's
not skillful, that's bad.
And so I went on my podcasts and
I, uh, and I apologize and I, uh,
admitted that that was wrong.
And also I think the term robbing,
it's totally wrong because robbing
implies that the person that you're, um,
it implies forcefully taking
something for someone.
Whereas if someone goes and does a show
with the ice house and Brian and said
he's not paying or it
didn't mention payment,
then you're entering into an agreement
where you're going to perform for free.
So it's more of the performers deal,
like it's,
you decided to go and do that. So Robin
is the wrong word. So there's that,
but watching it explode,
you know what I mean?
Watching the fireball grow
bigger and bigger. It's been, um,
a huge lesson for me, you know, and it
really has taught me like, fuck man,
you've got to learn to,
uh,
if you're angry and especially
your anger is at a friend.
And even though like, I think Brian
hates my guts permanently. Nah, he was,
we've been friends for like,
I don't know, seven years,
eight years ago. Let me stab me with
a pencil. I can with a fucking pencil.
I'm sorry for that.
I'm sorry that I did.
I'll tell you this. Let me
tell you this. I'm a lot less,
sorry that I stabbed him with a pencil
than I am that in a fucking public forum.
I called him out on something that I
should have addressed privately because
when I stabbed him with a fucking pencil,
he get Pocan my back on an airplane
when I'm trying to sleep man.
And I had to fucking fight back.
I don't feel bad about that
was retarded baby is stupid.
But that was just an instant
reaction to being annoyed.
What happened at the laughing skull
was using a public forum to address a
private issue and I think
that that is not fucking cool.
And the end result of that, even though
that podcast didn't get uploaded,
is that we've created a fucking car dash
Ian episode with a death squad and that
sucks man. There's a lot of
fucking people who've been
taking sides and and attacking
me or attacking Brian or like,
like all this stuff that ultimately,
so now what, what, what happens?
This is the fucking thing that happens.
You Watch this thing that started off as
a mid size negative energy ball turned
into a big negative energy ball and
then get fucking scattered and spread
throughout the fucking
Internet with people signing
up and trying to say hurtful
things or saying this person's right.
That person's wrong. This is good,
that's bad. This is why I say simplicity
is the most important thing man,
because it's like ultimately
you just have to say, I forgive.
You can pull it city man,
just forgiveness.
Just at some point. Simplicity
is forgiveness. No, forgiving
is a simple act.
It doesn't have to be complicated.
It doesn't have to be going into judge
Judy mode and stretching out the events
to see who was right,
who was wrong and how did you
do that and why did you do that?
It's just the simple thing of being
like, look, let's stop playing shit.
Ping Pong with negative,
it was back when we were talking about
earlier about like money being needed to
to keep score, fights
with friends. There's,
there's someone has to
be the one who was right.
Someone else to be the one who was wrong,
someone else's were the one who
one lawyer and someone has to lose.
It's like when people break up a
little divorced and you're like, oh,
she won that one. You know, she
got out of that one pretty good.
She gets this amount a month and you know,
that poor fucking guy,
he really lost that one. It
sucks. And yeah, it's funny.
It's weird. It's weird man.
And it's all ego based. That's all about
our whole society is about achievement,
forward progress,
you know,
treading into New Territories and taking
them over. I mean it's one of those,
yeah. Whether it's actual
physical territories like
new lands or whether it's a
technological territory, he's like new,
you know, new inventions and innovations.
We're always moving forward.
So like you have to like, okay,
you're out of a relationship.
How'd you do? I did great.
Why I only married that asshole for three
years and he has to give me $1 million,
you know,
look man. But you know,
like, so I think, uh,
I don't have anything else
to say about that. Right.
I think I'm done talking about that,
but I do want to say,
well he, his, uh, in his
defense, his, uh, what,
what he's upset about more than the fact
that he brought her up with a podcast
and did it like that and through them,
one of the bus that even in your apology,
you still said that he wasn't paying
the comedians and he did pay some of the
Comedians, you know, and apparently,
you know, I wasn't really, I,
I told them it'd be good
idea to pay the comedians,
but we never really had too
many conversations about
who got paid and who didn't.
It was up to his discretion.
Thomson Reuters,
some people got burnt Christ or something
that people got paid and so I'm good,
you know,
but there was different shows where there
wasn't that many seats that were sold,
you know, where he did his own shows. Two
shows a word that's successful. Right.
Okay.
So what,
so what this turns into at this
point is like real fucking like,
to me it's like, I guess so like
if the apology's not correct,
then basically what we've created now is
a situation where it's like you didn't
submit to me properly. You know what I
mean? I don't, I don't know, like, okay,
I know you play fucking Cat Stevens
peace train and said that you were, uh,
my friend. You know what I mean? Like,
like I know that you did that you
didn't do it in exactly the right way.
And then if that happens, then
it's like, okay, then what?
You didn't do this and I didn't do.
Now all of a sudden,
Shit Ping pongs happening again should
ping pong, you know what I mean?
And it's like, fuck man, like, isn't
like the, isn't it like the, the,
the best thing to do to like number one,
uh,
address this situation and I'm addressing
it publicly now because it was brought
in at the public forum. It isn't
the best that you do to address it
privately. Isn't that the number one,
like best, best way to handle it? Um,
and number two,
well boy, it wasn't his fault. It was
made public. It was really my fault.
I was explaining to the Ra why you guys
were in and are in an argument and you
know, in the middle of the
podcast we're just talking.
I didn't really stop and think whether
or not this is a smart thing to,
to re expose. Right. And, but, but,
but you must be upset
about how it happened.
And I know how I feel after every sort
of yelling argument that I've ever been
on. My was like, no, it was really good.
Tends to, I see someone saying, Fuck
Duncan Trussell in front of half,
possibly half a million people. That
felt really weird cause I, um, I,
you know,
like it's tough for me to imagine a
situation where I would be angry enough to
like try to publicly disparage
somebody in that intense away.
You know what I mean? I just, I, I
wouldn't, I don't think I do that.
And my thought was a
really fucking pissed. So
yeah, these trains were going to make
it all work out, bro. Well, that's my,
that's what I wrote.
So I'm going to come together.
He's trained by that
silly bitch.
This piece train asshole became a Muslim.
He fucking plus.
No Muslims are some of
something. Okay. Oh yeah.
But he was calling for Salmon Rushdie to
be killed when we got off a piece track.
It's crazy. Who was talking about how
the Quran says that someone rushed,
he's gotta go gotta go gotta go.
Recently I make a little [inaudible] cash.
Have a little bit of a comeback.
I saw him playing his use of Islam now.
Yeah,
Jack on Sa. It's very sad. Yeah,
that is a sweet song. Matt,
who's got a lot of great songs,
he's got some beautiful songs and he's
obviously an incredibly sensitive guy.
But back to the whole situation,
I think you have to treat your friends
the way you treat someone that you love,
like a wife, you know you, you go
to, you can't, you can't insult them.
You can't lash out at them.
You can't do it. It's a,
it's a shitty thing when it happens and
you got to make it all better after it's
over. And you've got to,
you've got to really,
truly feel bad about it and you got to
really truly sort of correct yourself and
make sure that you never put
yourself into such a situation of a,
almost like verbal combat with
a brother, you know? Yes. Um,
Brian for sure has some
maturing to do on an, you know,
and I think he's aware of it himself and
he started out at a different time than
we did. He's a good dude
though, man. I've, I've been
with Brian for a long time.
We've worked together for like a decade.
He's a good dude, man. He's, uh, you know,
he's got a lot of Manchild in them,
but that's,
that's part of what makes him funny. Yeah.
That's part of what makes him unique.
And PS, here's the fucking thing. No
one needs to be attacking. Exactly.
Nobody. You guys aren't,
there's no bad guys.
There's no need for there to be an enemy
involved here. It's crazy. Yeah. There,
there's no,
there's like,
there's this, it's like what we
got going on here with his foot,
whatever you want to call it, the death
squad, this podcast, our podcasts.
Is it an emergent art form that's
incredibly beautiful and all of us are
contributing to it in our own way.
And a lot of people seem really invested
in it and a lot of people seem to
authentically upset by
this fight. And, and,
and so I think like out
of respect for this,
whatever this weird fucking thing
is that we're building here,
we've got to like learn how to forgive
each other and to let bygones be bygones
because otherwise the community that
we're forming is weak, you know, and then,
and then in a week, fucking thing's
going to fall apart. You know, you need,
I think you need blow outs like this.
I would prefer for them
to happen in private,
but I think in this case it got
into the public eye fine. Uh,
the fact that it is in the public eye
creates even more of a reason to resolve
it in a civilized way.
That doesn't mean somebody gets
hurt or somebody gets fucking, uh,
excommunicated or somebody
gets like permanently mad.
It means that because if
we can't figure it out,
if we can't figure out how to
resolve something as silly as this,
then how can we fucking talk
about stub dropping bombs? No.
I mean, how can we stuck when that's
what that is in the macro, right.
You know what I mean? And that's
why I think it takes at some point,
if you look at the back and
forth that happened in war,
it's somebody did this to someone and
then they did something back in the night
and something back bigger and they did
something back bigger. It goes on forever.
At some point you just have to be
like, I'm sorry, I forgive you.
I'm sorry.
And that's it.
And that's when Brian goes fucked.
I could trust,
right? Yeah. I know, man. That's the
fucking day that, but, but you know what,
it's like, you can only handle
your side of the street, right.
You know what I mean? That's all
you, that's all that you could do.
You can only handle your side of fucking
things. That's all you can do. That's it.
Yeah.
You know,
I think all of us get caught up in life
and stress and shit and this and that.
And there's words that come out of your
mouth that are poorly chosen. This,
this is ideas that are
expressed selfishly. No, we
all, we all make mistakes.
Especially when you're, you're fucking
busy and you're not getting enough sleep.
Real stressed out, always in the
middle of a million different things.
Like I know you are, and I
certainly am. I ever make mistakes.
People make a lot of fucking mistakes.
You got to know when you'd been
friends with someone for a long time.
The essence of who that
person is. No, you gotta,
you gotta be a nice guy both when you
are in charge and when you are the
employee or the person has to listen,
follow directions,
whether you're the fan or
whether you're the performer,
whether the police officer or the guy who
has to talk to the cop because his car
got stolen. You know who in the fuck you
know, we, we have to figure out a way to,
to always communicate with respect.
It's just so hard to develop a human
being that's completely and totally honest
that we live in this world of and
half truths and bullshit lies.
And then behind the lies there's things
that are true but make no sense like
legislation,
laws and all of it adds up
to be this really confusing,
frustrating,
unfair feeling of life in general,
just as a pattern of your whole
fucking situation. But all of it,
all of it can be cured by the simple truth
that we have to start turning on each
other is if we are treating ourselves,
living another life,
if we are all this one thing that
is born into this world in various
circumstances and various biological
situations in various states of the world
and various various climates,
but at the soul of it all behind the
sex and behind that the, the, the, the,
you know,
the height and the weight and the
essence of what a fucking human being is.
Could, it could just be as easy
on you. You could be that guy,
you could be this guy, you were, you
are stripped of culture and language.
And what I am is the same thing.
I'm just going through this in a
completely different ride with a total
different flesh vehicle.
And we happen to see each other along
the journey and we'll become friends and
you know, to be in our struggle
together and enhanced each other.
But at the end of the day
with the same fucking thing.
And once we realize that I'm the same
with some poor fuck that was born in
Afghanistan, is living in a
cave. I'm the same as that guy.
I just got a real better roll the
dice and I was born in New Jersey.
You know what I'm saying?
I mean,
is that the only way we're ever going
to get over this hump of existence as if
we drop all the bullshit and then the
one law that we should all recognize,
the one thing that we should all practice
is the ideal that you were me an imu
and we are moving completely
different lives but inside the body,
inside that the booming of what
he is one who think of you.
I could easily be you. I can easily be
my mother. I can easily do this asshole.
It was down the street from me that I
can't talk to cause he's dumb. I can,
you can do this guy. I could be that
guy. I could have been born here.
It's just some crazy situation where
we may I be the very same thing living
through different epochs, living
through different biological identities,
lifting through different genetics and
different social circumstances and but at
the root of it all, we could be the same
fucking thing. And we essentially are.
Yeah,
we'll essentially are for sure.
It's our own individual experiences
that confused the fuck out of us. If we,
if we really started
treating people like that,
if you really looked at the word bite,
that,
and it doesn't always mean that you're
going to give that person everything they
want because then you could spoil you.
Well, that's right. I mean it's, you can't
be phony about it. You know what I mean?
Like you gotta like you have to address
it from a real place. You can't be phony.
But if you,
if you have as an intention
and dealing with conflict,
whichever one's going
to have wanting a that
wanting, not just to rev
resolution, but an evolution.
Yeah, that's it. If that's your
fucking intention behind it,
it's going to work out great. Yeah,
it's going to work out okay. You,
it might be turbulent and might be weird,
but if that's your intention,
then it's a lot different
than the intention being,
I'm gonna win this, right?
I'm going to conquer.
I'm going to be the one who comes out
on top that only creates more Shit Ping
Pong and more negativity in the world.
Right.
That's the thing that we've got to like
don and this thing with Brian and I'm
sure everyone's got an example of this
happening in their life or we'll have it
deal with it in a way that's
like accelerating the community,
making the community stronger,
making the community more.
How about just last karmic impact
outside of all that?
I mean it does get complicated and start
really ultra defining everything as far
doing it for the community,
but just do the do what is what feels
like the healthiest thing to do.
What's the healthiest thing to do?
Drop all the rest of the problems.
Trump on the motion.
Just drop it. It's done.
Trauma and learn from it and never
be that guy again. You know, we,
we have to accept that this was a trial
and error sort of a situation in life,
especially the generation that
you and I come from, you know,
you and your thirties me and my forties
we were essentially one of the first
generations to be awake.
We're one of the first generations to use
the internet and it's sort of exchange
so much information back and forth
with each other that will kind of
reformulating idea of how the
world works. You know, I mean,
we don't really necessarily trust our
parents that brought us into this thing.
We don't necessarily trust our parents
parents too, to have a full sort of uh,
an account of what, what really is going
on in this life biologically, physically,
geo,
politically.
We are one of the first generations to
truly have a decent grasp of it because
of our use of the Internet.
So we're a lot of what we're doing as
adults is essentially trying to re govern
our,
our own culture to re refigure out how
we're communicating with each other.
If the New York giants fans really want
to beat the fuck out of the Raiders and
they don't even know him, is that,
isn't there something wrong with that?
Like is it, could that not be us
on another side of the country?
When do you not understand that
you really want to go and you know,
you go to a fucking ball game in Philly
and they break your leg in the hallway
cause you're wearing the wrong shirt,
but that stuff happens. That's you man.
That's you on the ground
living a different life and
you just stomped on your
thigh bone and snapped
it. You know? And that is,
that's really unfortunate aspect of life.
This sort of a tribal thing that you know,
might've existed in that book,
the road in that movie. You
know what, what could happen
if the shit hits the fan,
but where we have to understand that this
shit's not hitting the fan right now.
It's not hitting the fan at all.
This is,
this is nothing like the shit hits the
fan. Right? Right. There was a guy,
but I was mentioning earlier that was
talking about how life right now that we
were unhappy but yet we live very much
like kings and emperors, you know,
did a hundred years ago,
which I thought was really stupid because
first of all the idea of we don't live
in like an emperor. You don't have
a Harem, can't order them around.
You can't have people
killed if they talk shit,
you don't have people can you around
on a giant tray every you go also,
you're not eating rancid fucking to
me. Yeah, you got a fridge. Yeah.
You're not dying from whooping cough
because nobody knows what the fuck it is.
And they think he got
possessed by a demon.
But can I tell you about something? I
don't know how long I've been doing this,
but please, can you look
something up dude? Yeah, sure.
Augmented reality, sandbox,
augmented reality sandbox, this fucking
thing man is he can't living in the best.
It's a Xbox connect set up over a
sandbox or the projector blasting flowing
water into it. So as you like move
your finger through the sandbox,
like water flows around
and like grass forms.
It's like the future of video games,
man.
Especially with this new quantum sand
that apparently computers can construct
into shapes they're talking about.
Did you find it? Whoa. Yeah Dude.
What the fuck is this man?
It's fucking bad ass.
So explain it one more time please.
It is an x-box connect that somehow
detecting changes in the terrain of the
sandbox and projecting water and uh,
grass and sand over different parts of it.
I think based on how high
or how low the sand is.
So if you like go really like if you hold
your hand over it makes water up here
running through the sandbox and if
you run your fingers through it,
I think water appears as though there was
like water under the sand at the beach.
You don't want my fucking computer
runs slow as shit probably when you're
streaming a podcast. When I'm streaming
a podcast. What's that about? Well,
it's cause I guess there's only a
certain amount of bandwidth that's weak.
Is it really that hard
to make a podcast folks?
I know every time I try to
go online it's slug like,
I'm sorry. So I was looking
that up with augmented reality.
I'm trying to pull up the youtube video.
It's just so cool.
It's just, okay, now
I'm looking at it. Wow.
And so how has it work?
Uh,
and the x box connect I
think identifies distances.
I don't know how it, how
it works. People have,
so you're drawing in the sandbox
and then as you scoop up Sam,
the sandbox, it, it's showing
on a projection screen.
It's projecting directly onto
the sand. Why am I above? Yeah,
rejecting changes in colors
and it looks very psychedelic.
Super sack about your trip. A kid out,
make kid make sand castles and that shit
man. Next level, next level sandcastles.
Check starcraft on that fucking
thing. I'm gone.
I'm gone.
You're going to star trek star craft
it every day in my life was just like
downtime till Prometheans
comes out. I'm just like, what?
I would like to clone Ridley Scott and
give him an infinite budget and just give
them all the acid and mushrooms she
needs and him and HR Geiger and just lock
them in a room together and just make
a million alien movies. I swear to God,
I'm in thinking about inducing a calm.
I just to wake up and yelled
to go to from atheists
want so awesome though. It's so
dorky. Delicious. I can't wait.
So you were saying about um, this, uh,
my, my lust to go see the Avengers.
I feel like I'm getting away
with something. I really do.
I'm going to bring the Mustang to the
stupidest fucking kid car that I had.
This fucking, I have a Shelby
gt 500. It's just rude,
loud, Super American car.
It's so American man.
Everything about it.
They don't make another Carl didn't know
no one in the rest of the world makes a
car like a Shelby Mustang slides
all over the place. It's really,
it handles pretty well considering I
went and test drove cars yesterday.
Man there are so fucking nice after
you've been driving around it.
89 fall out off cars or cars or the
one one my my number one technological
thrill. Like the thing that I enjoy the
most. I just love the craftsmanship.
I love how someone's created something.
I love the different philosophies
behind cars at the high revving cars of
Germany or the like the deep low
torque muscle cars of America.
I just,
I think they're fascinating to me.
It's they're moving works
of art that they sell.
You know like if you buy a new corvette,
like there's a lot of people that think
Corvettes or douchey cause a lot of
douchebags drive Corvettes.
Well Corvettes are fucking amazing.
It's an amazing piece of
construction and engineering do.
But isn't that a funny
thing where like Pete,
because people think they're
supposed to think it's not cold.
An object can get a douche
bag. Its reputation and most
of your with that object.
Sorry it was that my fucking
phone. Sorry. You have
ridiculous motherfucker. Yeah, a forest
horn. Oh okay. Turn that Shit on mute son.
I don't know how is almost
done on the side of it.
I won't turn down all the way
it goes to vibrate. Stupid.
The thing on the side of the
above when your fingers are,
when you fuck finger is that fuck
finger, that finger right there, man.
The chooses crunching and retarded.
There's a little lever on the top of the
side of your phone. The top of the side.
You see that? Yeah. That
shuts it to vibrate. Yes. Ah.
That changed my life so retarded.
All this shit.
How do you not know how to fucking turn
your vibrator eyes? The man at night,
that fucking warrants come waking
me up. Oh my God. You idiot
fucking idiot.
You didn't know how the fuck do you
have an iPhone and not know where the
vibrate button is can make me sad,
man. You fucking just
changed my life, man.
Fucking bother me nonstop to,
I've been looking at some of these
android phones they have now.
I know I get like a lusty
envy with certain phones,
but one of them have been
looking at is this galaxy note.
I've been watching videos and one of the
things that everybody keeps saying is
once you get this thing,
it's really hard to go back to her regular
phone cause it's five inches wide and
it's four G.
It's wicked fast is a crazy fast processor
and I'm watching these people use it,
play with it online and take pictures
with it and draw on the picture like he
right,
like almost stupid.
And you could send it in email or
sending a text message and browsing the
Internet. I mean it's fucking huge
man. It's five inches. Yeah man.
I feel like the little screen
on the iPhone, it's not enough.
I think it gives you eyestrain bad
thing. It fucks up your eyes. Just thing.
It's better. This fucking
things better. I may switch.
I may switch from the iPhone to this.
Not that it's switched from the iPhone.
No say that man.
But these new ice cream sandwich,
Google phones are pretty fucking
complicated, man. They're,
they're really bad at taking that
risk again. Knowing kiss my ass.
I had a fucking shit boy for so long.
It really not like those old Android's
though. I picked up a shit android once.
I had a shit android for one day and I was
like, this is a drunk, retarded iPhone.
It was really bad. This is perfect,
but these aren't like that.
These new ones are not like that.
This new operating systems called ice
cream sandwich and apparently it's the
shit they in the new Samsung Galaxy three
that's another one that just came out
in England. I don't think it's all out
in America yet. That's another huge one.
It's like 4.8 inch screen
and Norma screen not,
not quite as big as the note.
The note is like five plus I think five
three but it's a huge screen and like
when you touched the outside of it
rip, it was like water. It's like it's,
it's got the effect that there's water
on it. When you rub your hand across it,
it takes a snapshot of the screen
if that's all you have to do.
It's like you're a magician, which you
do that. They're bad ass man. Yeah.
Which is going to lead to a
lot of accidental screenshots,
but people are going to be fucking,
that dropped their phone in the
ground and it looks like it's a swipe,
but really it's just passing by a Dick.
Take pictures of ball sacs and
all kinds of unexpected shit.
All kinds of, what's the word we're
looking for? Candid, candid shot.
Camden. Random Vagina shots. Whoa.
What happened? This is an
adult to screenshots. Yeah.
There's a lot of the camera's view, dude.
My team. You know what I'm afraid of, man?
I'm afraid that like,
what's here's what's going to happen.
This is what I think's going to happen
to me when I get conspiratorial and worry
about the crazy shit we
talk about on here. Oh,
I think one day the feds are going
to come, they're going to take me,
they're going to do the old Bill Hicks
thing where they take you into a room,
but instead of showing a
video of an assassination,
they're going to show a screen
filled with mov and meet, jerking off
what one your camera is, right.
They're all there and next to it,
the different things.
I was jerking off to and they're going
to show me that and be like, hey man,
you want to keep saying the hippy shit?
You want to keep talking about that cause
look I want to keep talking and he'd
be boy, hey what's this? What's
this? Is this German? Is Porn junk?
And that you are looking at who's,
is it possible to convert the entire
government into a positive force?
Is it possible to have people that are
really looking out to do the right thing
and get it all together or is the
job of working for the government?
So fucking unrewarding and boring but
everyone just falls into a place of non
innovation.
Non-Responsibility thanking the diffusion
of responsibility that comes with the
corporation also falls upon you when
you're in government. It's just,
it seems so few, a few
tiles. It seems so huge.
It seems so impossible that you
just sort of give up and come.
You just become a part of the wave.
Right now it's,
I don't know how you fix it.
So like all I can think about is
like, uh, in the micro you fix it.
And if every,
if I'm,
the majority of people start improving
the their lives and the lives of people
around them and actively seeking to
put positive energy out in the world.
And maybe that'll sort of, um, uh,
transform the government
itself in a real way.
But as long as people are getting
caught up worrying about the macro and
thinking that everything's coming to a
screeching halt and everything's fucked
up and they might as well just live like
idiots and give up trying to be happy,
then shit,
we'll keep continue to perpetuate
itself in the neck in a negative way.
So I think the idea is it's like,
yeah, things are fucked up the world.
Nancy Grace's world is
a Shitty fucking world,
but let's not worry about Landlease
Linnux got strangled in the everglades and
let's start worrying about the way that
we're treating our fucking why for our
friends or our kids or whatever,
and deal with that.
And then if enough people
started doing that,
and I think a big change would
happen in the world, man,
definitely change.
Look,
everybody can change and everybody
can change their own environment by
surrounding yourself with other people
that are like minded. That is possible.
And that's one of the things that
I think that this podcast does.
We've talked about this
before, but it's a, it's,
it's important to recognize that
we're aware of this, that this,
this is not something that existed
when we were young. We didn't,
we didn't have access to people
that were just for sort of no real,
I mean there's no, I want to say
a no obligation. There's no real
direction that we're trying to go with us.
We are just trying to express
ourselves 100% honestly. Yeah.
There's no ulterior motive.
There's no agenda. There's no,
there's no deception. It's just this is,
this is how we really view the world.
Right?
And when you're stuck somewhere and you
don't have people like that around you,
this is the only way you can get that.
And through this,
it allows people to connect light,
mine,
likeminded people to connect through
Twitter and through Facebook and whatever.
And they seek each other out and improve
the actual environment they live in.
And then it starts these exponential
changes all over the world.
That's the one way, in my opinion,
whenever we change any government anyways,
expose them to new ideas that are more
satisfying than the stupid dumb conquer
model that they'd been using
since before the days of gangs.
That's it, man. We got to figure that out.
We have to figure out
what that looks like.
Well that's the, it looks
like the Internet. That's
sort of both sides. Reddit,
do you ever notice the
only thing that exactly it,
the owner knows the only
thing that doesn't, doesn't
want to hear your bullshit.
You know, there, there's, there's isolated
pockets, there's isolated, you know,
places where you can go like Stormfront
websites and we can do is go hang out
with only Nazis and you know,
they'll have, you know what I mean?
And we didn't do a lot of those out there.
You could just do that.
But the overwhelming
social network interaction,
the overwhelming experience seems to
be the distribution of information.
You know, there's good and
bad, you know? Good and bad,
but the district distribution of
information, the exposure of reality.
Yeah,
it's incredible man.
And it's like definitely if you look back
at history and the way power is always
fought to subvert the flow of information
and suddenly there's a thing that is
like a truth volcano now and there's no
way to put a fucking cork on it. Yeah,
no dude,
if we had this,
if this was a radio show and we
were in 1916 is a pirate radio show,
they put us in jail. Oh yeah. They
would come after us and punish them.
Jail giant difference between the world
of post 1993 which is really sort of the
one of the first few years of the Internet
being like a public entity that I can
remember and maybe it happened a few
years before that for the real hardcore
guys like the real hardcore geeks. But for
me, 1993 is about what it, and that's a,
that's a different fucking era.
There might as well been before that
there was no cell phones either.
All around happened at the
same time as well, you know,
essentially in a few years post,
you know,
it all kind of bubbled together into
one big sort of a community can of soup.
Yeah, man. It's incredible.
And it's also incredible
how positive it it can be.
Can Be. Yeah. Yeah. This, yeah,
this more positive for us, you know,
for sure and more positive at the shows
and what are people enjoying themselves.
We were having shows a way
we've never had before.
So the kind of shows were having where
we're going and thousands of people were
there and the thousands of people
are screaming and having fun and,
and this is just more massive burst of
positive energy will that massive bursa
positive energy all came out of doing
something like this, doing this podcast,
connecting with all those people out
there flowing their head with something to
think about while they're working,
while they're doing mundane tasks
where the commuting all of it for free,
all of it without an
agenda and all of that.
We'll see the what it does is it spreads
out more positivity and it makes you
want to write more shit and it makes you
want to perform more comedy and get you
have more material for them
and do more shows and okay. And
it fucking rocks your consciousness when
the, when the freaks you and say, Hey,
listen, I, I'm a, I'm a fellow,
my disciple of crawling.
Hey, why don't you check out this book
book for and then you order, all right,
I'll fucking get booked for,
and then you're reading crawling.
Suddenly you're like, holy fucking
shit. This is some intense shit here.
Some of this is right on and real or
that Guy Matt stacks from this info.
I love you.
He sent me all these fucking books.
I've been reading these books and getting
stoned and reading these books and
just start shuttering and stoner or like,
or
did you fucking getting the
Catholic Church? All this shit
set over.
The Catholic church is all coming from
this one fucking book that he sent to me.
And, and that's the
other cool thing. Yeah,
that's good.
If you don't know about this info,
just go out and get your being
lied to. Yeah. It's amazing.
It's amazing.
Anybody says there's no conspiracies is
a fucking idiot because like as we were
talking about with the nine 11 there
had to be a conspiracy in the dynamic on
the enemy's side.
So there are conspiracies and human
nature and they do pull things off and if
you don't think they have in the past,
you're being silly.
You're being incredibly silly.
That's how it runs.
Yeah. But yeah, it's, there's
obviously conspiracies.
There needs to be conspiracies. How about
every time you fucking, I mean, yeah,
there's many conspiracies and
huge conspiracies anyway. Yeah,
it's what the whole point is.
What we have going on here
is not a one sided thing.
We've got a conversation afterwards.
People where they, anytime, yeah,
they were connecting with
people and that's why it's
so cool to do those things.
We'll do after the show,
we'd go out and take pictures of
people for fucking hours for hours.
We just go wade out into the
crowd and take pictures. I'm
fine. That's right. Yeah.
And these people are overwhelmingly
cool. Overwhelmingly cool. I,
yeah, 99.9% nine nine
nine nine nine. Yeah.
And even the ones on our core just
fucking probably just freaking out.
Just a little too drunk. I have
noticed a little bit of that. Yeah.
Fucking poor drunks.
Wow. Sad bitches. Yeah.
But it's uh, it's, other than that,
it's been overwhelmingly positive and
that all came from this one thing.
You know, it all, it, all, it
all came from this one idea,
this desire to express yourself and
express information, discuss things,
and to force ourselves to have these
conversations on a regular basis.
And Duncan and I,
we started having these conversations
when he was working at the comedy store
and are very similar.
That's how we became friends.
Donovan was the guy who you'd
call and he'd say, Hey man,
I'm going to be in town Friday and
Saturday he drove me up and Duncan would,
you know,
he would write down the lineups and the
given the Mitzi and Mitzi would decide
like, where to put everybody. So
Duncan may not call him up. Hey man,
we'll be in town Friday. What's going on.
I'm like, dude, I just read this book.
Okay.
And we would go into these crazy fucking
rabbit hole conversations because
sometimes the phone wouldn't ring at
the comedy store for an hour, you know?
So you and I would just keep talking.
We'll just have long ass
crazy conversations about
all kinds of weird shit.
Yeah man. But you know, like you,
you pretty much gave me like my big break
cause you started taking me out on the
road with you when I sucked.
Well I, you know, you
always had potential.
No it wasn't that you saw that
and that meant a lot. Cause like,
like having like you'd be like,
hey man, like I can remember,
I'll never forget this shit man.
I can remember being in the Olr and doing
this joke. I don't even do it anymore.
But it was like being in
a bad relationship is like
having an octopus stuck to
your face every once in a
while it whispers to you.
Do you still have some dumb joke?
But I remember like you saw
that and after it you're like,
that was fucking funny
man. And I was like, Whoa,
Holy Shit Man Brogan thinks that
joke's fight. That was a big moment.
You really do help. Like a lot of young
comics man, you up a lot of fucking car.
You like really have like a, a, a sort
of patron thing happening with people.
Well that's nice if that's true. I, I,
I love comedy man is still my favorite
thing to watch as an audience member.
You know, I think it's the greatest art
form where is as far as me, you know,
like what,
what entertains me.
I'll just love watching a good comic
more than anything. So I, you know,
I love like helping,
I love watching guys become killers.
I remember watching Ari Shaffir go from
being the guy who was like kind of a
little bit uncomfortable on stage, trying
to find his feet to one day, you know,
just slowly but surely becoming a killer.
And now I just watch,
I'm so seeing Ari crushed in front of
thousands of people and I remember taking
him on the road. Yeah, I
remember I took him to Denver.
I was taking Mike and Mike Young
couldn't make it for some reason,
so it took Ari and Ari just fucking
lit the place on fire. And I was like,
God Damn, look at all I should fear. All
of a sudden he's a, he's a real comedian.
It's beautiful.
It's beautiful to watch your friends grow
and prosper and become real comedians.
Fucking encouraged me to do it.
The pop it ag and fucking crabs.
It could never work.
I'd be like, just do it. No,
fuck them. That's your bit.
It was awesome. Brilliant.
But a lot of fucking,
a lot of comments we're bringing people
on the road of them would not racking,
recommend before their sets be like,
hey dude,
do that fucking really
uncomfortable safety
cause I want to put it like to come out,
do a horrified crap.
Not just the crowd that's like,
like seeing someone bomb but a crowd.
It's like maybe seeing like either someone
who's as schizophrenia or like a say
tannic.
Well, you know, I mean, I had this
conversation with all he wants, uh,
on the road when we're talking about
trying out new stuff and bombing or you
know, or what have you,
you know, like the,
the willingness to take chances and
then sometimes it doesn't work out.
And he said, yeah, but sometimes you know,
you go on the road and you don't want
to take those chances. I said, well,
you don't have to worry about that
because you're opening up for me. Right.
So like it doesn't matter if you bomb,
never, you're never going to get fired.
I know that you're a funny comedian.
He, as long as you're trying be when it,
when I wouldn't have that feeling is
when someone wasn't trying to get better.
Right.
And you know,
there are people that just get to a
certain point and they just completely
plateau and then they redo the same
jokes for a decade. I mean, we,
we all know comics that are like that.
I have no desire to be
around those types of people.
But the type of guys like
you or like all your,
anybody who was improving and always
working on your stand up, I was like,
go fuck around up there, man. If it
doesn't work out, it doesn't matter.
It doesn't matter. It's all
about developing. Oh Dude.
But you don't necessarily
tip toe around the fact.
And some of our jokes don't work.
Gotta be honest about that.
But I want you to be honest to me too
mean Eddie Bravo, uh, said to me once,
he goes, man, I don't like that
joke you're doing. And I said, yeah,
I'm kind of forcing it, right? I'm like,
yeah, thank you for telling me that.
Thank you.
Cause I'm fucking forced in that joke.
That was a joke that I would
like kept in my arsenal,
but I'd committed to for whatever
reason, it just wasn't good. Now though,
that kind of Shit helps, man. That's
it. Fuck yeah, man. You need to know.
You need to know when you're,
you're being repetitive.
you, you overuse the word fuck.
And you make for an uncomfortable moment
when someone's listening to you, you're,
you're doing when you're on stage is
you're essentially controlling the pattern
of thought that goes
through someone's mind.
Cause you're going to bring up various
topics and various subjects that put
various images and feelings and people
and you have to get them to appreciate
where your mind is coming from.
Well if you add an and a bunch of extra
frogs or you're stammering or you're
coming off like a goof, which oftentimes
we do, especially on this podcast,
we got too high. Like I couldn't
remember the young Turk thing earlier.
So we go into a stammer mode,
you know,
but no one wants to listen to that and
then allow you to continue controlling
the pattern of thought.
That's why it's an uncomfortable moment.
That uncomfortable moment is the
realization that you at that moment you
shouldn't be in control.
And unfortunately you are.
Cause there's only two people in the room.
Regardless of the fact that half a million
people are going to listen to those.
There's only two people in the room,
two people.
Sometimes I've gotten on stage and fucking
forgotten what's about to come out of
my mouth.
That's the worst thing where you're like
in the middle of something and that's
happened to me a couple of times where
I'm like too high and I'm like Shit,
do this joke and we gotta be careful.
You know one sucks when you do more
than one show in a night. Yeah.
And then you get rid of like confused.
Well because when you
do more than one show,
what happens is there's a state
of mind when you're on stage,
which is like let's,
let's just consider it getting
on the trolley and sitting
in the same seat. Okay.
You get on the trial,
you were in that same seat.
That is the state of mind that
you at when you're on stage.
Like I'm in this driver's seat and
here we go. I'm on the trolley. Yeah.
Well when you're on the trolley
again for the second show,
and especially if you do it like I do it
where I don't really have necessarily a
particular order. I think I have an
idea probably how I'm going to close,
but I don't know how the fuck I'm going
to open and I might go from here to
there and I might jump all over the place.
And when I do that then I can get lost
and say, I don't remember if I did it.
Alrighty dude. It's um, yeah, it's
really easy to lose your focus up there,
but thank God it doesn't
have all the time. You know,
I just realized this too, man thing a
problem. I've got to fucking piss dude.
Why don't we go pistols ramp this up.
I can talking for two hours.
You wrap it up now. 50 minutes.
Yeah, let's wrap it up now.
So I think to wrap up the,
the Brian thing, you know,
I think we all learned a little
something from this and I think, yeah,
online feuds and just spats and
all that stuff is just bitch shit.
You know, what are the bridge?
It's gross. Dun, Dun, Dun.
I don't have to have a city of limitation
to lift yourself above this life.
When to get you back in the isolation
tank to plug the fuck out of it.
Sun doing pre sales for the
first time ever in my life.
He's a comedian. I'm like,
goodness,
tee shirts.
We're going presales for tee
shirts@theshopatduncantrostle.com
they're awesome.
It's one of them is a pyramid.
Killing a fucking vampire bat.
If they order appreciate. How long
was it before the, it's the shirt.
Watch the ship and I put the order and
on the 15th so then how long will it be
til they actually get it? It's on the
side. I think it'll be a couple of weeks.
Couple of weeks. He can handle
a couple of weeks. Folks,
give something to look forward to.
If you get them out,
it's 20 bucks and if you wait, it
said $2 extra and you can't. Duncan,
you're crazy. You're a marketing
genius. How I tell you dude, my penalty,
my web guy,
he came up with that sounds like a creep.
Gimmicky mother fucker. Just kidding. I
can't help myself. The greatest stuff,
Steve, I don't even know you
and I love you, but you, I mean,
you really establish that we are,
we doing more podcasts this week.
I'm not sure who I'm working out
the next couple of ones this week,
but a more red Ban as well.
Don't worry,
we'll bring my little buddy back
into the mix. Um, and so, uh,
I want to thank everybody that
came to New York this past weekend.
We had the fucking time of our lives
mean can you can't get better than that.
I played it yesterday. I played the
audio of Joey Diaz going on stage.
Oh my God. I'll pull it up again
just because it's so ridiculous.
It doesn't good. And you'd
go Piss, I'll play this
because I played it from Mrs Rogan
and she almost didn't believe it.
It doesn't really doesn't seem real.
This is a Joey Coco Diaz
going on stage in New York.
[inaudible]
he hasn't even had a
chance to say a word yet.
He had to stop them. It
was just crazy. It was, um,
it really represent to all of
us. Uh, some, some sort of a,
a real obvious paradigm shift and uh,
you know,
I can speak for every of us, for
Joey, for Ari, for Dunkin, you know,
we're very, very thankful that
all this is happening. And uh,
for me personally as a a guy
who, uh, you know, I had,
but I was the one who was on television
and I was the one who was taking these
guys on the road with me to see guys like
Joey all the sudden become recognized
and people appreciate him for what he is.
Joey,
it's always had a hard time with people
recognizing his brilliance because he's
so crazy and out there and wild with
his comedy that until he was famous,
until he was like an established
personality like he has now,
it's almost like it's too hot to handle
is too much to deal with people nobody
wanted to have in middle. That was
like a big deal with, with Joey Diaz.
Like he couldn't get work on the
road because he couldn't headline,
but he couldn't middle because nobody
wanted Joey Diaz on in front of them
because he would just go
up and fucking destroy.
But my philosophy of comedy came
out at the comedy store and uh,
first of all what that meant was that we
were all brothers in the comedy store.
So it was like if I was going to
take anybody in the road of me,
I take my comedy store brothers who was
always Ari Shaffir was always Duncan
Trussell. It was, uh, you know,
different people. See I'm Tripoli,
different people that are comedy store
brothers and Joey was always a comedy
store brother. And so when I started
taking them on the road with me,
there was two reasons. One that cause
he was a comedy store brother and two,
because the, the philosophy of the
comedy store also was you had to go,
he wanted to go on with
a bunch of other killers.
You didn't want to be the only
guy that was good. You wanted to.
The comedy store was a about a
bunch of different guys being good,
like the old outlaws of comedy,
you know,
with called the bow and Tennyson and
like there's a bunch of guys that were
really good Ron shock.
There was a bunch of these dudes that
were really good together and that,
you know,
so so t taking guys like Joey on the
road and exposing him to all these people
and then seeing them go on stage and
these fucking gigantic rounds of applause
he gets. It's beautiful. I couldn't be
happier. It's amazing to me. It's like,
um, it's like a vision
that's sort of coming true.
We have this idea when we
used to do these, you know,
when we were calling ourselves a death
squad, we used to do these little videos.
I hired Brian do these death
squad videos and there was,
some of them were really short.
Like one of them was Joey Diaz talking
about Mcginn this gay guy and the gay guy
beat him up. I mean there's
a, there's a bunch of all,
I'll probably get Brian to try
to find them on, organize them.
And put them online because some
of them were really classic,
but the idea didn't really come to
fruition in the terms of doing it through
these little video clips.
The real way to get to know a guy like
Joey is to get to know him on the podcast.
If you him go off for hours and
hours about criminal stories,
about sneaking to some girls fucking
bedroom at two o'clock in the morning and
ain't no pussy and then
escaping and the that.
This is the crazy shit that he did.
You know the Lucy snore Bush story has
become so big that a guy at in Atlanta,
did you see the stickers
that he made? He had, hello,
my name is Lucy Snore, Bush
teaching two stickers. There were,
there were amazing man.
It just to see that happening and
to see it all come out of this,
this one idea that you know,
that man,
I get this really talented group of
friends and I think that if we all stick
together and sort of, you know, help
each other out and pump each other up,
we make each other better and we,
we make each other funny era and we
create like a bigger footprint of positive
energy. All of us together have one
giant footprint of positive energy,
but it has to be only back.
And that's why it was very important
to resolve this whole issue with, uh,
with you and Brian. And you
know, as I said, it's not as,
it's not a clear cut case of either one
person having done the right thing and
there's errors made on both sides,
both in the actual act itself and in
the discussion of the act afterwards.
There's, there's some incorrect thinking
and it's a negative thinking going on,
but hopefully we'll work all that shit
out. The most important thing is we're a,
all of us in this fucking thing together.
And the last negative bullshit that you
can spread the law of forgiveness that
you can give the more you can call
people up and go, I'm fucking sorry,
I'm really sorry in. The more the person
listening you can go, it's all I do.
It's all good dude.
The more we can do that in this life,
the more we realize that we're
all capable in various situations,
various circumstances of
making colossal mistakes.
It doesn't necessarily mean
you're a horrible person.
It just means sometimes we
don't respond well to stress.
Sometimes we don't respond
well to character issues
and we need to learn and we
need to grow and he may be
more appropriate than I am.
You may be further ahead,
but show me, show me, show
me how you got there. Don't,
don't chastise, don't be angry
and don't hate child elevate.
We can all make this. We're not going
to make utopia. It doesn't exist,
but we can all make our environment and
the people we come in contact with a
little bit better and then my, when
recording, we'll stop in three minutes.
I just got a warning from Ustream.
Listen power to the people.
I love all your dirty bitches. We
do. And uh, we'll be back soon.
Thanks to the fleshlight.
Go to Joe rogan.net.
Click on the link for the flashlight and
of the coordinate Brogan and you will
save yourself some money and thank you
to [inaudible] dot com that's [inaudible]
it entering the code name Rogan end.
You will get 10% off any and all orders.
Thank you for everybody.
Thank you for everybody for tuning in.
I'm selling my Brazilian translation.
Thank you everybody for tuning in.
We'd love the fuck out of you.
Why don't you buy.